Frédéric Penard, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de vos activités
dans SOS Méditerranée et sur l'Aquarius.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Je suis Frédéric Penard, j'ai 43 ans, je
suis un humanitaire.
Ça fait un peu moins de 20 ans que que
je fais ce métier, que je travaille,
j'ai eu l'occasion de travailler pour
différentes ONG humanitaires à
l'international,
souvent dans l'urgence, très souvent
dans l'urgence dans pas mal de de zones
de conflit, de zones de catastrophe
naturelle. Et donc j'ai petit à petit
appris sur le tas dans ces dans ces ONG
à gérer des programmes humanitaires et à
essayer de de faire en sorte que les
actions humanitaires soient le
[grognement] mieux calibré possible, le
plus les plus cohérentes possible. Et
puis il y a il y a quelques mois
maintenant, il y a il y a 6 mois
environ, mars dernier, j'ai je suis
arrivé chez SOS Méditerranée qui mène
cette belle cette belle mission en tout
cas que je trouve belle de sauvetage en
Méditerranée centrale. un contexte que
je connaissais pas du tout
et particulièrement tendu, passionnant,
quelque chose qui voilà qui moi m'a
énormément attiré parce que
pour moi cette mission a énormément de
sens et c'était absolument évident que
qu'un humanitaire doivent être là
aujourd'hui en Méditerranée centrale en
2018.
Quel Quel background vous avez ? Quel
type d'étude vous avez faite ? Est-ce
que vous avez un milieu socio-culturel
prédest qui vous prédestinait à ça ?
J'ai fait des études de sciences
sociales, sciences politiques. J'ai fait
du droit. Euh
je me cherchais un petit peu, je
cherchais à travailler à
l'international.
J'ai réfléchi un peu à la communication,
le journalisme,
euh aller vers l'autre, réfléchir. C'est
c'était un petit peu un petit peu mon
ambition. Je j'ai pas sauté directement
dans l'humanitaire. J'ai fait deux trois
choses avant et euh l'humanitaire à un
moment m'est apparu et je suis rentré
vraiment par des des aspect très
technique de finances, ce genre de
choses avant de de pouvoir prétendre
gérer des missions, leur logique, leur
leur sécurité. Euh mais l'humanitaire
pour moi a était une une façon de voilà
d'aller au-delà des autres et puis
d'avoir une place un petit peu
constructive, on va dire dans ce monde
avec tous les débats et toutes les les
ambiguïtés de de de ce métier
évidemment.
Combien vous êtes payé ?
Alors, je suis payé 3400 € net par mois.
Depuis combien de temps ? depuis mars
dernier.
Comment vous expliquez que les les ONG
euh soient de plus en plus repoussé sur
les les conflits humanitaires euh sur
les sur les OPEX, les opérations
territoires extérieurs que l'armée
appelle comme ça ? Comment vous
expliquer que les groupes sur place
traitent les ONG euh non pas à leur
juste place d'ONG mais comme agent
perturbateur extérieur ou comme
potentiel euh biais d'infiltration de
certains services ?
C'est un vieux débat hein. Ça fait
quelques années maintenant euh une bonne
vingtaine d'années que cette question
monte. Euh et
à tort ou quoi ? Rison
à tort. Probablement euh à tort. Euh
mais on est dans dans un système où les
ONG ont ont énormément de mal. En tout
cas à l'international l'expérience que
que j'ai eu la chance d'avoir.
Quel pays ? Euh, j'ai pu j'ai pu aller
en Syrie sur le conflit récent sur des
visites. Je j'ai connu j'ai beaucoup
géré de projets au au Darfour dans le
passé. Euh voilà, par exemple en Côte
d'Ivoire au moment du conflit. Et dans
tous ces dans toutes ces ces contextes
de conflit, la place des humanitaires
n'est plus évidente. Mais ça fait c'est
c'est c'est un lieu commun, c'est ça
fait des années qu'on qu'on le dit,
qu'on le perçoit. euh les acteurs du
conflit ne reconnaissent plus la
l'existence
ou le fait que puisse exister euh un une
action impartiale, neutre, guidée par
euh pas d'autre intérêt que euh celui de
simplement euh alors on dira ici
sauvegarder la vie humaine, assister des
personnes, mais quelque chose de
d'extrêmement neutre. C'est quelque
chose qui qui est assez récent dans
l'histoire he ça a été inventé au 19e
siècle. Henri Dan, Solferino, cette idée
que voilà dans le pire du pire quand
quand les États se tapent dessus, quand
les gens se battent, il peut y avoir une
place pour une certaine humanité y
compris dans ces dans ces moments
extrêmement déstructurés.
Et ça, c'est quelque chose que qui se
perd, qui n'est plus respecté par
personne, par personne. Les les grandes
ONG humanitaires le disent, le le
répètent.
D'abord parce que simplement c'est
rarement des des conflits entre États de
moins en moins. En 2018, c'est des
conflits entre factions, entre groupes
par proxy. par proxy. Euh et donc
et tous ces groupes sont pas euh sont
beaucoup moins euh
euh dans un système euh d'état de droit
où euh tout ce qui a pu être construit
depuis plus d'un siècle en temps de en
terme de convention, de droits de la
guerre, de convention de Genève, tout ça
a énormément de mal à être respecté par
ces groupes-là. Et donc effectivement le
le fait de de respecter le fait que on
doit l'accès à des humanitaires, on doit
minimiser les pertes de population
civile, on doit garantir l'accès aux
soins, on doit avoir des des repost
enfin tout ce droit de la guerre qui a
été construit depuis maintenant plus
d'un siècle, tout ça, c'est des choses
qu'on volé en éclat avec l'éclatement
des conflits. l'éclatement des conflits
depuis, on va dire depuis la fin de la
guerre froide, mais grosso modo, c'est
quelque chose qui voilà qui est monté
depuis depuis la fin des années 80. Et
c'est dans ce contexte là que les que
les grandes ONG humanitaires, enfin
toutes les ONG humanitaires qui
travaillent en zone de conflit ont
énormément de mal à trouver ce qu'ell ce
qu'on appelle, j'aime pas trop
l'expression, mais l'espace humanitaire
comme si c'était un territoire qui nous
a qui nous appartenait. C'est c'est pas
la question l'espace c'est quelque chose
de c'est le concept de d'avoir un espace
où on puisse travailler avec ce respect
des principes humanitaires.
On reviendra on viendra sur ça. Mais
pour les belligérants, vous êtes
peut-être un élément perturbateur dans
leur stratégie, mais on pourra on pourra
y revenir.
Euh les
qu'est-ce qui qui est-ce qui vous a
organisé votre départ en Syrie ? Vous
êtes parti comme ça tout seul avec un
sac à dos ? Vous aviez contact sur
place, vous aviez un fixeur,
vous êtes parti avec un état, vous êtes
parti avec des journalistes, vous êtes
partis comment ? Je suis parti dans le
cadre de d'une mission, j'ai je
travaillais à l'époque pour l'ONG
Solidarité Internationale qui menait des
missions depuis la Turquie au nord de la
Syrie, des missions d'assistance en en
aide alimentaire et en eau. Euh et
simplement, je suis parti, je crois une
de semaines ou quelque chose comme ça en
visite simplement, je gérais les
programmes et donc oui, il y avait
escorté par qui ?
On était pas escorté. pas escorté,
c'était euh le j'ai oublié j'ai oublié
le nom maréa je crois le entre Alep et
la frontière turque vraiment à quelques
encablures de la frontière turque.
Vous êtes passé pour rentrer en Syrie
par la Turquie ou par
par la Turquie ? Par la Turquie. C'était
le tout début du conflit euh enfin le
tout début une époque où on était avant
l'existence de de l'État islamique par
exemple et on était dans un moment où il
était en possible de pouvoir de pouvoir
accéder sans voilà de pouvoir accéder
directement depuis la Turquie. Ensuite,
je sais que ça c'est compliqué mais je
suis passé à autre chose et à d'autres
d'autres projets.
Euh revenons au aux ONG. Il y a eu
quelques petits scandales de salaires
mirobolant dans certaines ONG ou des
budgets qui étaient
pas très pas carrés. Est-ce que vous
avez en est-ce que vous avez entendu
parler de ça ?
Il y a eu plusieurs scandales ou
plusieurs débats en tout cas.
Qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
vient en tête ?
Moi, je pense à un scandale pas sur les
salaires mais plutôt sur lui celui sur
les sur les le harcèlement qu'il y a pu
y avoir autour autour d'oxfemme
notamment l'année dernière ou l'année
d'avant. Euh globalement les grandes ONG
sont aussi maintenant font partie du
système depuis maintenant les années 70
voire pour certaines d'entre elles
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps.
C'est un business.
C'est pas un business. euh pour les
avoir fréquenté depuis maintenant une
vingtaine d'années, je sais que
la l'ensemble des personnes qui
travaillent dans ces organisations ont
un vrai engagement qui qui qui est
difficile à qui est difficile à nier
tout tout simplement
l'espace humanitaire n'est pas simple à
à trouver. Euh il y a des dynamiques
internes. Certaines organisations ont
pris énormément de place. Elles sont
devenues énormes euh parce qu'elles ont
aussi comblé euh comblé un manque de de
multilatéralisme entre les États, de
d'actions communes euh et tout ça crée
des dynamiques qui bah voilà qui mènent
à parfois à des excès. Euh j'ai envie de
dire c'est un peu une crise de une crise
de passage à l'âge adulte pour certaines
ONG qui ont maintenant comme moi plus de
40 ans quoi.
Vous vous avez vu le dernier spectacle
de Jérémy Ferrari ?
Pas du tout,
on vous le conseille.
Merci. Je crois que c'est un de pièces à
Beout.
D'accord.
Il parle des ONG derrière où ça pique ça
pique sévère. Revenons à notre sujet.
L'Aquarius, un bateau qui fait plus de
70 m de long.
77 m de long. Merci. Euh le tonnage,
aucune idée.
Aucune idée.
Je suis pas malade.
Capacité capacité d'emport, c'est
combien ?
Combien de personnes on peut prendre à
bord ? Alors l'Aquarius est fait pour 60
passagers 60 pardon membres d'équipage
et passagers. C'est son
c'est c'est comme ça qu' qu'il est
enregistré.
Et dans l'activité de de recherche et
sauvetage que que mène SOS Méditerranée
avec l'Aquarius, on a pu monter dans le
passé jusqu'à quasiment 1000 personnes
1000 personnes secourues à bord, ce qui
est une limite très haute. En général,
au-delà de 700 personnes, c'est c'est
quelque chose qui qui qui deviend qui
devient particulièrement problématique.
Simplement, les actions de de recherche
sauvetage sont supposées théoriquement
être des actions exceptionnelles. Ça
doit arriver une fois de temps en temps.
C'est c'est des solutions d'urgence
et et donc il y a pas vraiment de norme
en la matière. Simplement il y a
simplement la la stabilité du navire, la
sécurité du navire et pour nous, on sait
que la la jauge est maximum autour de de
700 personnes. Tout dépend du temps, la
météo et cetera.
[soupir]
L'autonomie du bateau.
Alors, c'est un bateau qui est qui est
un bel outil. L'aquarus a été construit
il y a maintenant
plus de 40 ans. Ouai. Par les par les le
gouvernement allemand. C'est c'est un
c'est un bateau de garde-decôte
qui avait une fonction assez similaire
d'ailleurs au départ et il est devenu
ensuite je crois un navire de soutien
aux flottes de pêche en en mer du Nord.
Et dans ce cadre là, dans ce de cette
cette vie antérieure de l'Aquarius dans
les années 80, l'Aquarius a été en
partie transformée
parce que son rôle était d'aller au
devant des flottes en mer du Nord qui
restent des mois en campagne de pêche
pour les réapprovisionner en carburant,
pour les réapprovisionner en nourriture,
pour les
pour faire des soins pour donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y avait il y a déjà à bord
un espèce de de une petite clinique, un
petit hôpital.
Donc c'est un c'est un navire qui a
énormément d'autonomie. Il a des soutes
beaucoup plus grosses que d'autres
navires de la même taille. Donc on né
jamais allé au bout des réserves de de
carburant de l'aquarius. On peut rester
longtemps en mer avec l'aquarius.
Le le coût de fonctionnement par jour.
Le coût de fonctionnement est de 11000 €
par jour. C'est le chiffre qu'on a
toujours
communiqué. C'est c'est une moyenne ça
correspond grosso modo à enfin ça
correspond exactement à notre budget
annuel divisé par le nombre de jours
parce que le navire qu'il soit à qu en
mer a des coûts qui sont sensiblement
sensiblement les mêmes. Il y a il y a
pas de grosse différence. Le carburant
en est une mais les frais portuaires en
sont une autre. Donc 11000 € c'est une
moyenne sur l'année. C'est le coût
depuis le début d'opération depuis début
2016. Donc
le bateau est acheté, il est loué, il
appartient à qui ? Alors, le bateau est
pas du tout il est pas du tout euh
la propriété des SOS Méditerranée.
Euh le bateau est la propriété d'une
petite compagnie allemande qui s'appelle
Yas Moon Shipping euh qui en possède
quatre. Donc c'est pas c'est pas un
grand un grand armateur. Euh et nous
nous sommes l'affriteur, donc nous
louons le bateau euh avec un contrat
d'affraitement qui est renouvelé chaque
année avec des conditions très très
spécifiques de quelle est la mission du
bateau, comment comment on va
l'utiliser, quels sont les les
engagements qu'on va prendre vis-à-vis
de l'équipage, quels sont nos droits et
devoirs réciproques. Voilà, un contrat
de un contrat de location simplement.
Donc on affette on affrête l'aquarius.
Vous avez une autre question
sur l'aquarius ?
Oui. [grognement] Vous veniez de dire un
truc ?
Le
donc c'est quelqu'un c'est c'est un
affraiteur. Votre budget annuel c'est
c'est combien ?
Le budget de l'opération est d'un peu
plus de 4 millions d'euros par an.
D'accord. Et le budget total de votre
ONG c'est 4 millions aussi.
Bah oui. Alors on oui.
D'où vient l'argent ?
Alors l'argent de SOS Méditerranée est à
95 % sur les comptes de l'année
dernière. probablement un peu plus cette
année 95 % issus de de fonds privés de
donation
d'individus
et d'entreprises de quelques entreprises
mais des
je les ai pas en tête c'est plutôt des
petites entreprises des produits partag
je j'ai pas en tête que d'énormes
entreprises qui nous soutent grand group
non pas du tout pas du tout
George Soros n'est pas derrière
non je l'ai lu aussi 1000 fois George
Soros je l'ai lu pas que pour SOS
Méditerranée pour plein d'autres choses
Non, ça c'est typiquement dans le dans
le domaine des fake news. Non, SOS est
financé par des donations de vous, de
moi, de d'individus principalement en
France, même si nous sommes depuis le
premier jour une organisation
européenne, c'est SOS Méditerranée s'est
créé simultanément en Allemagne et en
France, puis c'est étendu en Italie et
en Suisse.
Comment on fait pour vous donner des
sous ?
Et ben, on nous envoie un chèque. On
nous envoie un chèque tout simplement.
Alors, il y a une adresse sur le site
internet, c'est une boîte postale. Euh
c'est comme ça que ça arrive.
Simplement, on peut aussi nous euh nous
faire un don par internet. C'est comme
ça que la plupart des donateurs nous
soutiennent.
Déductible.
C'est déductible aussi.
66 %
66 % des impôts en France. Oui.
[soupir]
Euh, revenons à nos moutons. La dernière
opération, ça date de quand ?
La dernière opération date de fin
septembre.
Vous aviez eu des petits soucis de
pavillon. Nous avions eu des petits
soucis de pavillon. Nous avons eu à
répétition euh depuis depuis début août
euh quelque chose d'assez incroyable
dans l'histoire maritime. On a pu euh je
suis pas marin historiquement, je donc
j'apprends tout ça. Je j'ai j'ai pu en
discuter avec des gens qui qui
travaillent dans la marine marchande
depuis depuis des années. Euh et tous
ont dit que les déboirs de l'Aquarius
depuis maintenant 3 mois sont des choses
inédites qu'ils n'ont jamais vu. Et
peut-être ça vaut le coup de les d'en
reparler un tout petit peu.
Gibraltar qui était le pavillon de
l'aquarius. Alors pourquoi Gibraltar ?
J'ai j'ai vu souvent cette question.
simplement parce que l'armateur quand on
lui a loué le bateau, le le pavillon
était Gibraltar. Et c'est quelque chose
qui était tout à fait tout à fait
pratique. Euh Gibraltar nous a signifié
son intention de dépavillonner
l'Aquarius
prétextant le fait que on mettrait en
danger notre propre équipage et les
personnes qu'on secours. Donc c'est un
petit peu on marche un petit peu sur la
tête quand même de de de l'entendre dans
ce sens-là prétextant qu'on qu'on
mettrait les gens en danger et que donc
on ne remplit pas les conditions de de
sécurité et de sûreté exigé par
Gibraltar. Donc ça c'est le premier
épisode de début août. Euh faut savoir
que notre priorité à nous, elle est pas
d'argumenter pendant des années ou des
mois avec un pavillon, avec un état sur
la légitimité de de de
nous poser telle question, de nous
bloquer, de nous dépavillonner et
cetera. Notre notre priorité, c'est
d'être en mer. Donc la la ce qu'on a
réalisé tout de suite dès qu'on a eu ces
ces informations de Gibraltar et on a
travaillé avec l'armateur du bateau et
on a pu sécuriser un autre pavillon. On
a réenregistré l'Aquarius qui est devenu
l'Aquarius 2 d'ailleurs mi-aût auprès de
auprès du Panama. Et là coup de tonner à
peine la première opération menée avait
sous pavillon Panama. Le Panama euh à
son tour nous a signifié, enfin a
signifié à l'armateur son intention de
dépavillonner l'arm de dépavillonner
l'Aquarius.
Et là, on en a appris un petit peu plus
parce que le Panama pour justifier sa
décision euh a été beaucoup plus clair
finalement euh et nous a dit que
l'Italie l'Italie avait donné
un rapport, on n sait pas plus et que
visiblement d'après ce rapport
continuer à pavillonner l'Aquarius. Et
c'est ce que dit lev le Panama.
continuer à pavillonner l'Aquarius
créerait des problèmes diplomatiques et
des problèmes que le Panama ne souhaite
pas avoir. Et pour nous, ça a été un
petit peu révélateur du fait que ce
qu'on supposait déjà probablement avec
Gibraltar du fait que c'est pas
simplement une mesure administrative et
d'ailleurs c'est pas dans les dans les
attributions d'un état du pavillon de de
retirer son pavillon comme ça. Les seuls
cas de de retrait de pavillon qu'il y a
dans la marine marchande, c'est pour des
choses comme un accident écologique, on
a créé une marée noire énorme, on n pas
respecté le droit du travail, enfin des
des fautes claires, précises, avérées,
on n pas respecté tel élément technique,
tout ça. Il y a rien de tel qui a été
reproché à l'Aquarius. Et c'est ce qu'on
a compris avec cette argumentation du
Panama, le fait que il y avait une
volonté délibérée, manifeste de nous
empêcher de mener cette mission de
sauvetage en mer Méditerranée, en
l'occurrence du gouvernement italien qui
a donc fait pression sur le Panama pour
que le Panama prenne cette décision.
Donc le Libérien est venu à votre
secours.
Alors le
c'est c'est plus long que ça. Le
l'Aquarius a est revenu à Marseille.
recours retour à la carte à la case
départ. À cette occasion, on a pu en
appeler un peu aux citoyens euh dire que
c'était intolérable, qu'il fallait se se
manifester, dire que on va pouvoir en
reparler, mais dire qu'il y avait un
devoir d'assistance, qu'on devait qu'on
devait pas laisser ce navire sans
pavillon, qu'on devait trouver une
solution. [soupir]
Nous sommes depuis en train de chercher
une solution. On a fait appel à tous les
États du monde pour essayer de de
trouver un pavillon qui permette à
l'aquarius de continuer sa mission. Mais
simplement les jours avancés et pour des
questions administratives, c'est très
délicat de d'être sans pavillon. Donc
l'armateur de façon provisoire pour
l'instant a immatriculé le l'aquarius au
Libéria et donc l'Aquarius est donc
libérien depuis 15 jours maintenant. Euh
simplement les autorités libériennes ont
assorti cette immatriculation du fait de
de ne pas continuer une mission de
sauvetage. Donc c'est pas une solution
pour l'Aquarius. Aujourd'hui, on est
toujours en recherche urgente d'une
solution d'un pavillonnage de l'Aquarius
pour pouvoir continuer cette mission qui
semble pourtant le béaba et le la base
de l'activité maritime.
Vous avez demandé à la Libye ? On n pas
demandé à la Libye. Non, on n pas
demandé à la Libye parce que ça serait
un petit peu compliqué. Euh
l'état du pavillon a quand même la
responsabilité sur la sécurité du navire
et on a vu notre zone d'intervention, la
Méditerranée centrale, on a un enjeu
avec la Libye. La Libye est un pays
instable,
détruit
en conflit. encore récemment, il y avait
des combats dans Tripoli. En tout cas,
un un un pays qui ne sort pas de son
instabilité. Euh
ça changera peut-être dans les années
qui viennent. euh c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui. Euh et donc euh
aujourd'hui, c'est quelque chose qui
nous est très important dans le dans la
justification de de notre mission euh et
dans toute cette discussion qu'il y a
autour de de notre activité en
Méditerranée centrale, c'est euh la
Libye euh ne peut pas et n'est pas
considérée comme ce qu'on appelle un
portur et donc c'est pas un endroit où
un un navire de sauvetage peut débarquer
des personnes qui l'auraient secouru.
Vous avez des armes sur l'aquarius ?
Non. Pas du tout.
Vous avez des sociétés de sécurité
privée pour assurer votre sécurité ?
Pas du tout. Aucune.
Est-ce que vous avez engagé
un médiateur ou quelque chose comme ça ?
S'il y a des prises d'otage de votre
bateau ? Non.
Vous avez déjà reçu euh des petits
bateaux qui ont essayé de prendre
contrôle de votre navire ou pas du tout
?
Non plus.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Des petits bateaux qui ont essayé de
prendre contrôle de notre navire.
Ouais. Un peu comme sur la corne de
l'Afrique.
Non, on n jamais de pirate à bord. Non.
Vous avez jamais été approché par des
pirates ?
Non, pas ma connaissance. Non.
Une question d'internet. A-t-il déjà été
approché par les services de
renseignement ?
L'Aquarius,
vous ou l'aquarius ?
Euh, les services de renseignement, on a
pu être alors en tout cas qu'on sache
parce que par définition les services de
renseignement se déclarent pas toujours
comme tel. Euh les services de
renseignement ont probablement euh
régulièrement, on a on a travaillé
pendant très longtemps en à partir d'une
base arrière jusque jusqu'en juin
dernier hein, d'une base arrière en
Sicile. Euh il est probable que dans ce
dans le cadre de cette activité euh
évidemment tout débarquement était
assorti d'une enquête de police sur dans
quelle circonstantait fait les le
sauvetage, dans quelle circonstan ces
personnes que qu'on secourait en mer
entraient sur le territoire italien.
probablement qu'il y avait des du un
travail de de renseignement et de
derrière. J'en ai pas la preuve. J'en ai
pas la preuve.
Vous êtes sur écoute
euh probablement.
Les Français ou les Italiens ?
Aucune idée. Aucune idée. Pourquoi je
dis probablement ? parce que dans des
des des affaires juridiques qui sont
arrivées pour d'autres collègues de
d'autres ONG de sauvetage, je pense
notamment au Juventa, on sait que
dans dans l'argumentation de de l'État
italien contre contre le Juventa,
certaines conversations étaient
retranscrites dans les dans les PV
simplement. certains même certains
micros avaient été avaient été mis euh
au sein du bateau. Donc on sait que
l'activité des ONG de sauvetage a été
particulièrement surveillée dans le
passé et l' probablement encore. Euh
voilà,
[soupir][souffle coupé]
depuis que vous avez commencé euh les
opérations de sauvetage qui on le
rappelle est un droit est un devoir pour
le droit maritime, combien de personnes
vous avez secouru en totalité ? 29523.
Quelle proportion d'homme ? Quelle
proportion de femme ? Quelle proportion
d'enfant ? Quelle proportion de femmes
enceinte ?
Je con ouh là, je connais pas tous ces
chiffres par cœur. Euh je dirais que on
est à
70 % d'hommes euh probablement plutôt
jeunes, 20 40. Euh [soupir]
je à vérifier hein, t tous ces chiffres
sont sur nos sites internet. Je devrais
les connaître par cœur, je ne les
connais pas par cœur. Euh nos
proportions de de femmes et d'enfants,
donc 30 euh ça dépend énormément des
embarcations. Euh c'est quelque chose
qui euh qui a qui est assez frappant.
Euh on a eu, je crois plus de 200
opérations différentes, donc 200
sauvetages ou oui sauvetages
je crois même de façon pratique et des
transferts d'autres d'autres
embarcations parce qu'il y avait tout un
système de transfert des gardes de côte
italien vers l'aquarius et cetera. Euh
et en fonction en fait c'est c'est c'est
très particulier, on on a des
embarcations parfois avec des gens tous
de la même nationalité et parfois euh un
mix de différentes nationalités parfois
alors les principales nationalités sur
l'Aquarius, on a on a beaucoup de euh de
gens de d'Afrique de l'Ouest, on a
beaucoup de gens du Soudan, d'Héritré,
d'Afrique de l'Est, Soudan Hériterré.
Euh on a eu parfois des gens du
Bangladesh,
des Syriens à certaines pas énormément
mais on a eu des Syriens euh et puis
globalement je crois que c'est quasiment
une centaine de nationalités différentes
de non peut-être pas une centaine de
nationalités une soixantaine de
nationalités différentes de de personnes
qu'on a pu avoir depuis 2 ans et demi
sur l'aquarius. Vous avez jamais eu de
canadien en fait.
De canadiens rarement. Non. Jamais.
Rarement. Non. Jamais.
Que des États où ça craint un peu, où il
y a de la guerre, où il y a de la
récession économique.
Pas [raclement de gorge] tous. Pas tous.
Si on regarde la nationalité des gens,
des des pays des pays en guerre
évidemment
pas mal.
Des pays en dans l'extrême pauvreté.
Oui, aussi. Euh ensuite des pays,
l'Afrique de l'Ouest est un bon exemple,
c'est plus compliqué. rentrer dans le
détail dans l'Afrique de l'Ouest
des Ivoiriens par exemple euh la Côte
d'Ivoire n'est plus complètement en
conflit mais il y a des zones où c'est
où c'est très compliqué et et on on est
probablement dans des dans des dans des
logiques où les gens étaient aussi dans
dans des logiques de migration
économique.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que tous
ces gens-là sont partis de Libye et que
finalement euh
votre nationalité c'est quelque chose,
mais la situation que vous que que
à laquelle ces gens essayent de que ces
gens essayent de fuir, c'est la
situation de Libye. Et donc à ce titre,
pour moi et pour SOS Méditerranée, tous
ces gens ont fuit une zone de conflit.
Ils ont fui la Libye, qu'il soit
originellement euh dans un parcours qui
les a amené de du Bangladesh en Libye de
et parfois c'est pas un parcours
construit jusqu'en Europe. Euh il y a
des gens comme ça dans on a on a fait
des dizaines des centaines de de
d'entretiens avec les gens qu'on a qu'on
a pu croiser sur l'aquarius qu'on pu
nous raconter leurs histoires. toutes
les histoires sont différentes, mais
c'est toutes toutes ces ces démarches
étaient pas euh automatiquement une
démarche pour aller vers l'Europe. Euh
il y a eu beaucoup de de gens sur
l'Aquarius qu'on a eu qui étaient dans
une logique où par exemple ils allaient
en ils étaient allés en Libye pour
chercher du boulot en Libye parce que
c'était c'était une source de de boulot.
Ça c'était il y a encore quelques
années. Et puis ils sont retrouvés
coincés après le au moment du conflit en
Libye, ils sont retrouvés coincés et au
bout d'un moment c'était une
échappatoire simplement. On ça
présente combien ça ?
J'ai pas j'ai pas les chiffres. C'est
des témoignages qu'on a eu. On a aussi
des gens qui viennent d'Afrique de
l'Ouest qui ont été qui
quel type de pays ?
Soudan par exemple du du Darrefour.
Enfin je je hériteraiit Soudan euh
hériteraiit soualie. Euh
et c'est des gens qui fuyant ces pays-là
se sont retrouvés au Tchad et on
comprend quand ils nous racontent leur
leur parcours que petit à petit ils sont
tombés un petit peu dans dans les mains
de passeur et ils sont devenus
extrêmement dépendants finalement voir
complètement
la démarche au début était probablement
autonome fuir fuir une situation et puis
au bout d'un moment ils sont devenus
complètement happés par un système où
ils sont raquettés on leur demande de
travailler pour rembourser des dettes.
il s'enfoncent dans des dettes et puis
ils sont emmenés dans dans le coin d'à
côté et en fait la Libye est un petit
peu le de ce qu'on comprend la la
l'arrivée de de tous ces gens, de toutes
ces histoires qui viennent de de
différentes routes. Bangladesh, moi
c'est quelque chose qui m'a est toujours
extrêmement surpris. Comment peut-on
même géographiquement, je je n'arrive
pas à comprendre la route qu'on qu'on
fait quand on fuit le Bangladesh ou
quand on part du Bangladesh pour arriver
en Libye. Arriver en Libye, ça veut dire
être passé par plein de choses. Euh
le
pardon le C'était quoi la question ?
Vous venez juste
on va on va en poser une autre. euh
la la proportion de de des bateaux que
vous
Ouais.
que vous sauvez en Méditerranée, est-ce
que vous avez identifié par exemple tel
type de constructeur ? Quand je dis
constructeur, c'est-à-dire tel type de
passeur fait toujours le même type de
bateau avec le même type de nationalité
ou par exemple les zodiaques qui
ressemblent à tel type de zodiaque, vous
avez remarqué que c'était toujours les
mêmes. Donc à mon avis ça, est-ce que ça
fait comme à Mayotte
où il y a des constructeurs de bateau
dans les comors ?
des quoi ça qua et rien qu'à la forme du
bateau, à la qualité de la résine qui
est qui est utilisée, on peut dire voilà
ça vient de chez lui ou ça ça vient de
chez lui.
C'est beaucoup plus difficile à à
identifier. On a on a eu la grande
majorité des sauvetages qu'on a fait
sont des bateaux en plastique. Je j'ose
même pas les appeler des des zodiaques
parce que c'est la qualité est pas faite
pour que ça flotte plus de quelques
milles.
des choses qui sont fabriquées, me
dit-on en Chine, qu'il y a tout un
trafic de de de ces embarcations qui
sont grosso modo à peu près de la
qualité de d'un jouet d'un jouet de
piscine à peu près pour vous donner une
idée ou d'une bouée pour pour enfants.
Simplement vous l'imaginez sur une
dizaine de mètres de long, euh
2 m de large, 2,50 de large et vous
imaginez 120 personnes là-dessus. Euh et
donc beaucoup de sauvetages ont été de
ce type-là,
un ce qu'on appelle un rubber bot, un
bout de plastique avec un fond plus ou
moins solidifié avec du du contreplaqué
avec fait à la va vite hein avec des
clous qui sortent.
On a récupéré plein de gens
malheureusement blessés parce que on
tassait là-dedans pendant pendant des
heures. Euh
un tout petit moteur derrière
et puis euh des gens qu'on a qui nous
racontent assez systématiquement à peu
près le même mode opératoire. Euh alors
leurs histoires sont différentes. Ils
viennent de de centre de détention puis
ils ont été embarqués, ils savent plus
trop puis on comprend qu'ils ont été
probablement dans des centres de
détention illégaux. Vous parliez,
c'était ça votre question, vous parliez
des esclaves. Euh ça fait un an, ça fait
un an qu'on a eu ce reportage de de CNN
où c'est ça a été monté montré au grand
jour, mais euh des gens nous racontent
ça aussi. Ils ont été
forcés à travailler pour rembourser une
dette. Ils ont été torturés pour que
pour que et filmé en même temps pour que
les les images soient envoyées au pays
pour que pour que les gens
les gens ont été frappés, les gens ont
été violés, les gens ont été forcés
d'assister à des viols, forcés de violer
des gens, enfin peut-être des des tout
un tas de choses horribles.
[toux]
[raclement de gorge] Et donc ces gens
sont dans ce système euh [souffle coupé]
ils sont baladés d'un endroit à l'autre
et puis d'un seul coup un matin la dette
a été payée, le le le transfert a été
envoyé du pays par la famille ou
simplement il faut remplir un bateau euh
[gémissement]
et [raclement de gorge] il nous raconte
se retrouver sur des plader en camion au
milieu de la nuit, se retrouver sur une
plage et être poussé littéralement dans
ses dans ses can entassé. à 120
personnes
et euh parfois de force. On a eu des
témoignages de de personnes recueillies
sur l'Aquarius qui disait avoir voulu
s'opposer parce qu'elles ont bien
compris que ce bout de plastique ira pas
bien loin et que là on est voilà, elle
risque elles risquent leur vie et forcé
à monter y compris par les passeurs. Euh
forcé à monter, c'est quelqu'un avec une
arme.
Quelqu'un avec une arme. On a eu on a
récupéré sur sur l'aquarius des gens
blessés par balle. euh parce que parce
que au moment de l'embarquement, il y
avait eu des tirs
[soupir][souffle coupé] euh et ces
gens-là sont poussés, vraiment
littéralement poussé à la mer.
Un endroit au large de la Libye
où on a souvent récupéré des
embarcations, se fait fait des
sauvetages. Non, pas du tout. Au large
des eaux libiennes dans les eaux
internationales.
C'est une zone de plateforme pétrolière.
Euh, il y a une zone au large de la
Libye, au nord de la Libye où il y a des
plateformes pétrolières et et souvent
les passeurs disent aux gens "La lumière
là-bas que vous voyez". Donc imaginez
une plateforme pétrolière à 60000 des
50000 60000 des côtes, c'est l'Italie et
les gens avancent et on est à
12e du chemin pour aller jusqu'en
Italie. Donc c'est euh les gens sont
voilà sont poussés comme ça à la mer et
puis ensuite ils sont à la dérive et
s'ils ont un peu de chance, ils tombent
sur un bateau. Euh et si pas s'ils ont
pas de chance, c'est le temps de le
temps de survie de leur embarcation qui
va déterminer leur sort et et et
ces gens périssent en mer. aujourd'hui
en depuis 2014 euh l'Organisation
internationale d'immigration, le
l'agence des des Nations-Unies qui qui
essaie de tenir un décomte, c'est pas
c'est pas simple.
Comment ? Et d'ailleurs
alors
donc l'OM considère qu'il y a 15000
personnes à peu près qui sont mortes en
Méditerranée centrale depuis depuis
2014. Euh alors comment ils font ce
calcul ? faudrait leur demander. Ce que
je comprends, ils font ils travaillent
par ils ont une méthode qui qui ne varie
pas a priori depuis depuis 2014 et ils
essayent de de de procéder par
témoignage, c'est-à-dire de d'essayer de
de reconstituer à partir euh du départ
par exemple. Souvent les départs euh des
plages libiennes se font à plusieurs
embarcations et en recoupant les
témoignages des gens, on sait que
peut-être il y avait cinq embarcations
qui partaient et il y en a que trois qui
sont arrivés. Donc on suppose que les
deux autres, comme elles sont ni
revenues en Libye ni ont été déclarées
par un navire les ayant secouru, on peut
avoir une estimation du nombre de
personnes qui sont décédées et puis il y
a tout un travail qui est fait par les
les Nations Unies et puis par toutes les
organisations en Italie hein qui était
l'endroit où beaucoup de ces ces
personnes étaient débarquées jusqu'à
très récemment de de recoupement.
des des personnes au pays aussi
s'inquiètent de savoir le le devenir de
leurs proches et petit à petit on essaie
de réconcilier des chiffres. Voilà.
Est-ce que les services de
renseignement, l'État français ou l'État
italien avec ces satellites surveillent
les
passages de passeurs, les camps de
passeurs, les centres de détention ?
Est-ce que vous avez eu des discussions
ou est-ce que vous avez des informations
à nos communautés ?
J'ai peu d'informations sur l'activité
des services de renseignement. Ce qui
est intéressant, c'est que la
Méditerranée centrale, je parle pas trop
de la Libye pour le coup, mais la zone
des des eaux internationales entre la
côte nord africaine et la côte la côte
sud-européenne.
Euh c'est une zone où dans dans ce golfe
naturel du de la Libye, entre la Tunisie
et la Libye, c'est pas une zone où il y
a énormément de navires marchands. Il y
a il y a il y a peu de passage. pas la
zone de de trafic de de la plupart du
trafic international qui va entre
Gibraltar et et le et Suè. Euh et
pourtant ces dernières années, il y
avait énormément d'activités. Il y avait
énormément d'activités. beaucoup
d'avions, beaucoup de beaucoup de
navires militaires. Euh les Européens
depuis euh depuis maintenant 2 ans euh
depuis la déclaration de mal de 2017 euh
ont mis beaucoup de moyens euh pour
renforcer la surveillance, le contrôle
du trafic et donc dans ce cadre là, il y
avait énormément de de navires de
différentes opérations de de l'Union
européenne, des gouvernements européens,
des navires militaires, des avions.
Voilà, il y avait beaucoup de monde et
toute cette tous ces navires, tous ces
avions
ont pris une part absolument essentielle
et importante dans les sauvetages. C'est
quelque chose qui se dit pas assez. On
parle beaucoup des ONG. Euh il faut
savoir que jusqu'à juin dernier, je tout
a changé depuis juin mais jusqu'à juin
dernier, les ONG toutes confondu, la la
dizaine d'ONG, maximum la dizaine de
bateaux qui qui essayaient de faire le
travail que fait SOS Méditerranée de de
secours
faisait à peu près 20 % des sauvetages.
Tout le reste, les 80 % restants étaient
faits par des navires gouvernementaux,
par les gardes de côte italiens, par les
forces de
à la louche, ça représente combien de
personnes ? et 20 %. Alors le nombre de
sauvetage a a beaucoup changé entre 2017
et 2018 he mais en 2017 c'est 120000
personnes qui sont arrivées en Italie se
globalement sauvé par l'ensemble de ces
de de ces navires et en 2018 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on a une baisse
très importante du nombre de du nombre
d'arrivées en Italie. On parle de 20
23000 personnes à peu près
à cause de Salvini,
à cause de toute une architecture qui a
été savamment mise en place pour
par les Européens, par l'Union
européenne parce qu'on pointe du doigt
beaucoup l'Italie mais l'Italie n'est
n'est que la côte européenne la plus
proche de la Libye.
Euh
toute cette architecture a eu pour
ambition de de de gérer d'externaliser
la gestion des des frontières de l'Union
européenne et de pas avoir à gérer ces
questions compliquées en mer en mer
Méditerranée et de les faire gérer par
les Libyens et d'éviter de faire en
sorte que les départs ne que les gens ne
partent plus de Libye.
Euh donc
ça fonctionne,
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne qu'en partie
parce que 23000 personnes, c'est c'est
énorme et c'est surtout ça fonctionne
sur le nombre de départs. Il y a
beaucoup moins de départs et finalement
moins de départ c'est peut-être on
pourrait se dire moins de danger, moins
de risque, moins de mort mais beaucoup
plus de morts. Beaucoup plus de morts
relativement. On est à euh 1000 1000
1200 morts en Méditerranée central cette
année.
Euh
vous avez pensé à porter plainte contre
crime contre l'humanité
auprès des Nations Unies, auprès de la
haie ? Non,
on y a pensé souvent.
simplement aujourd'hui, c'est quelque
chose qui qui dépasse nos moyens, qui
dépasse
euh la capacité qu'on a aujourd'hui,
toute l'énergie qu'on a et c'est très
ancré chez SOS Méditerranée dans dans
nos équipes, dans nos équipes, dans nos
équipes de softur et de marins, c'est
[souffle coupé]
d'être en mer. C'est là qu'on a une
utilité et cellea été d'autant plus ces
derniers mois où il restait une poignée
de bateau.
Les gardes de côte italien s'étant
retiré de la zone. Les navires de
l'Union européenne s'étant savament
éloigné pour éviter d'avoir des
problèmes diplomatiques avec l'Italie
dans le débarquement. On s'est retrouvé
les les navires commerciaux faisant
parfois, on l'a vu, on l'a entendu à
quelques sur quelques rotations récente,
un petit peu la sour d'oreille, des
alertes de détresse, il y a il y a ce
genre de choses qui commencent à
apparaître. Il ne restait que les pardon
ils ont des radios sur les embarcations
?
Non, ils n'ont pas de radio. Euh ce qui
c'est les passeurs qui préviennent les
centres de secours avant de les
balancer. plusieurs méthodes. Euh
il y a eu pendant très longtemps euh
on envoy les les les passeurs envoyaient
trois qu rubberat simultanément
et donner à l'un ou à l'autre des
rubberat un un téléphone satellite avec
l'instruction
d'appeler le centre de coordination des
sauvetages de ROM euh après 1h ou 2h ou
3h ou 4h enfin plutôt plutôt 3 4h euh
c'est-à-dire dire une fois que ils
étaient certains que ce bateau serait
loin des côtes libiennes et à partir de
là, le centre de coordination de de Rome
prenait en charge l'alerte comme c'est
le devoir de tout centre de coordination
et euh mettait en œuvre tout ce qui
était nécessaire. Et c'est la logique du
droit maritime faisait intervenir
l'ensemble des navires sur place. Donc
les navires d'ONG, les navires
gouvernementaux, non gouvernementaux, ça
n'a aucune espèce d'importance. Il y a
un devoir de toute embarcation de faire
le maximum pour venir au secours du
d'une embarcation en détresse.
Quand Marine Le Pen dit que vous faites
le
l'auxiliaire des passeurs, le ça vous
fait quoi ?
Bah ça nous fait mal. Ça nous fait mal
parce que bah parce que c'est faux.
C'est complètement faux.
Ça sous-entend un une espèce de
complicité avec ce qui se passe en Libye
et c'est un petit peu confondre
la conséquence. On est là en train de
traiter et de de de de parer à
l'urgence, hein, de de faire en sorte
que des gens se noient pas avec la cause
et on a rien à voir avec la cause
aujourd'hui.
On n'a rien à voir avec tout tout tout
ce qui se passe en Libye, avec ce
système de passeur, avec
et et ça c'est un discours qui qui
malheureusement
a tendance à s'encrer,
qui n'est pas spécifique à la
Méditerranée centrale. D'ailleurs euh on
dit souvent des on en parlait en début
d'entretien que [souffle coupé]
oui, les ONG sont complices des des
problème qu'ell qu'elle prétendent
qu'elle prétendent
soigner ou
c'est un vrai enjeu. Aujourd'hui, euh il
y a cette fameux mythe, ce fameux mythe
qui est repris très souvent par par pas
mal de responsables politiques et on le
dénonce systématiquement.
Lesquel ?
des responsables politiques. Euh
monsieur Salvini, vous en parliez, on
est un euh mais des journalistes euh des
des responsable politiques euh français
euh l'ont fait récemment. Euh cette
histoire de
les ONG sont complices des passeurs ou
en tout cas sont un sont un comment dire
une incitation. Le fait que des gens
soient là pour secourir sont une
incitation au fait que les gens partent.
Ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le pool factor
en anglais. on serait une espèce de
d'aimant, un espèce de de d'attrait et
ça ça d'espoir. Et donc par notre simple
présence, on créerait nous-même le
problème qui fait que des gens partent.
Non, des gens partent d'abord parce
qu'il y a un push facteur. Des gens
partent de Libye parce qu'ils ils
s'enfuent de Libye. Et ça c'est assez
incohérent parce que l'ensemble des
responsables politiques lisent aussi les
rapports et ils sont publics.
Il y a pas de secret, enfin en a
certainement mais il y a pas de secret
sur la situation en Libye aujourd'hui.
Il y a pas de secret sur les centres de
détention, l'esclavage, on en parlait.
Pourquo ils font rien ?
Pourquoi ils font rien ? Peut-être ils
ont pas trouvé les clés pour stabiliser
la Libye, mais c'est un problème
effectivement, il faut intervenir
alors en Libye, il faut avoir des action
forte en Libye pour faire en sorte que
ce problème se résolve à en Libye pour
que les gens soient pris en charge pour
que pour que tout ça cesse, ces abus.
Mais aujourd'hui, ceci n'ayant pas lieu,
des gens continuent à traverser, des
gens continuent à fuir et à la fin
et et à la fin à mourir. Aujourd'hui, on
est là nous pour essayer de sauver des
vies et c'est la seule ambition qu'on a.
Donc non, on n'est pas un facteur, un
aimant qui attire les gens. Pas du tout.
Et d'ailleurs, il y a il y a il y a il y
a un bon contreexemple à ça qui qui est
assez intéressant.
En 2014, c'était bien avant la création
de de SOS Méditerrané,
les Italiens, les gardes-de côte italien
ont mené une opération massive parce que
parce que cette mer Méditerranée, faut
pas l'oublier en tant que qu'Européen,
cette mer Méditerranée, c'est c'est un
peu la source de notre histoire. C'est
c'est pas l'étranger, c'est c'est c'est
notre mère aussi
cette mère Méditerranée. Et ils sont
allés ils ont monté une opération de
grande ampleur parce que personne
faisait rien pour essayer de de de
porter assistance à toutes ces
embarcations qui essayaient de traverser
la Méditerranée dans cette Méditerranée
centrale. C'est ce qu'on appelait
l'opération Marinostrou.
Et puis euh au bout d'un moment, sous
pression d'ailleurs de leurs collègues
européens, euh les Italiens ont été ont
arrêté on arrêté cette cette opération
Marine Strom parce que on les accusait
eux, on parlait pas d'ONG à l'époque, on
accusait le gouvernement italien par le
fait de simplement faire son devoir,
d'aller porter assistance à des
personnes qui étaient à leur porte qui
étaient en danger. On les accusait
d'être un pool facteur. Déjà à l'époque,
ce discours était était là et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles Marinos a
été arrêté [souffle coupé] et à l'époque
les chiffres sont assez clairs.
Quand Marin Strom s'est arrêté, il y a
eu plusieurs mois de longs mois pendant
lesquels il y avait aucun navire de
secours dédié. Il y avait pas de navire
de guerre de côte, il y avait pas de
navire militaire dédié, il y avait pas
de navire d'ONG. C'est l'époque où SOS
Méditerranée et d'autres se sont créés
pour compenser justement cette absence
de de Marinostrou parce que les États
faisaient plus leur boulot. Et pendant
toute cette période où il y avait pas de
navire euh il y a jamais eu autant de
départ. Donc le lien entre existence de
secours et le fait que les gens prennent
prennent la mer et se mettent en danger
ou effet retard
n'est pas n n'est pas du tout n'est pas
du tout avéré ou
ou effet retard. effet retard sur
plusieurs mois, c'est quand même assez
délicat à envisager aujourd'hui. L'effet
retard, alors je pense pas que les gens
planifie leur départ de depuis le Soudan
avec l'idée que l'Aquarius sera en mer
et que du coup le le chemin est tout
tracé. D'abord, il est loin d'être tout
tracé.
Aujourd'hui, on parle de pour parler
d'effets retard, on parle de
probablement au moins 600000 personnes
qui sont bloqué dans cette situation,
dans dans cette situation cfcayenne en
Libye. Et pour ces gens-là, oui, il faut
trouver des solutions sinon elles
finiront par prendre la mer un jour.
Donc 600000 en Libye, plus d'lon7 en
Turquie, 2 millions en Turquie.
Oui.
Jordanie un petit peu. Il y en a combien
en Jordanie ? Je ne sais pas en
Jordanie, j'ai pas le
On vous reproche aussi de de
pas déposer les les gens que vous sauvez
en Tunisie ou en Algérie. Est-ce que
vous avez déjà essayé de de déposer des
gens sur la terre ferme sur des pays de
la région un peu plus stable ?
[grognement]
Alors non euh parce que il y a une règle
qui est assez claire, c'est que quand on
effectue un sauvetage, euh il y a deux
règles claires en en droit maritime,
c'est que chaque capitaine, chaque
navire a l'obligation de faire tout ce
qui est en son pouvoir pour porter
assistance à une embarcation en
détresse. Ça c'est clair, ça souffre
aucune exemption et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de défendre tous les jours avec
l'aquarius. ce devoir d'assistance qui
qui doit pas être mis en cause, il y a
aucune raison qui le soit et c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important.
Il y a une autre règle qui est
secondaire mais qui est très importante
aussi, c'est que les sauvetages ça se
fait pas n'importe comment et que ça se
coordonne avec les États. Et donc c'est
pour ça, c'est dans ce cadre là que les
États, tous les États,
la plupart des États ont un centre de
coordination des sauvetages. Et jusqu'à
présent,
nos sauvetages étaient coordonnés par le
centre des sauvetages de Rome de
coordination de Rome. Et le le centre de
coordination de Rome nous a toujours
indiqué les côtes italiennes comme étant
un lieu de débarquement. Donc c'est pas
l'Aquarius qui choisit où débarquer. Ça
c'est aussi une quelque chose que que
les que les gens peuvent croire mais
c'est c'est pas simplement le capitaine
qui décide tiens aujourd'hui je vais
aller débarquer en Libye ou à Malte. Ce
sont les États qui doivent trouver une
solution étant de en fonction de la
situation des gens à bord.
La situation des gens à bord euh
on la connaît pour la Libye, on la
connaît. Ce sont des on la connaît
globalement avec le le nombre de
personnes qui ont pu arriver sur les
côtes européennes depuis depuis des
années. On sait que c'est des gens qui
s'échappent de Libye et qui ont besoin
que [grognement] leur leur demande, ça
veut pas dire qu'il qui qu' qu'ils
auront du succès, mais que leur demande
de protection internationale soit
considérée. Et jusqu'à présent, cet
examen de leur situation, de leur besoin
de protection internationale ne pouvait
se faire que dans un sû et unsure
italien. Et c'est comme ça que c'est
dans ce cadre là que le que le centre de
Rome nous indiquait les côtes
italiennes. Tout s'est compliqué
évidemment depuis juin depuis que
l'Italie a fermé ses portes.
Quand on vous reproche de faire passer
des terroristes
à bord de l'Aquarius, il y a pas de
migrants.
Ça peut paraître bizarre ce que je dis.
Il y a pas de migrants, il y a pas de
réfugiés, il y a
des hommes.
Il y a des Voilà. Alors, il y a des
êtres humains, il a il y a un mot même
dans l'endroit maritime qui est pas très
joli mais qu'on qu'on utilise les
survivants. C'est comme ça que le droit
les les appelle.
Donc des personnes secourues. Euh
le devoir d'un capitaine, c'est de et
c'est quelque chose qui est ancré dans
les conventions euh dans la convention
Solace, hein, de de 74 qui date du
Titanic, hein, l'assistance en mer.
Euh le devoir du capitaine, c'est de
porter secours à des êtres humains.
il a interdiction d'une certaine façon
de
d'en savoir plus finalement parce
qu'après c'est plus son boulot de
capitaine, son le boulot de savoir
est-ce que ce sont des gens qui sont
[soupir][souffle coupé]
des migrants, des réfugiés qui
légitimement ont droit à la protection,
n'ont pas droit de la protection, qui
sont dangereux, qui sont pas dangereux,
qui sont toutes ces questions-là euh
sont pas des questions pour un
capitaine, ce sont des questions pour
des États et c'est dans ce cadre que ces
gens-là sont des
C'est des questions qu'on vous reproche.
Est-ce qu'on Est-ce qu'on transporte des
terroristes ?
Non, c'est pas Est-ce qu'on transporte ?
J'en ai aucune idée.
J'en ai aucune idée aussi.
Mais on vous le reproche.
On nous le reproche.
Vous l'avez déjà entendu cette phrase ?
Je l'ai déjà entendu. Je l'ai déjà
entendu. Oui. Est-ce que les gens Est-ce
que des terroristes sont passés par la
mer ? Peut-être. J'en j'ai pas plus.
J'en sais pas plus parce que simplement
la question c'est que on vient
on vient assister des êtres humains
simplement des des humains.
Je il y a c'est pas une question si
c'est une question internet j'ai pas
vérifié le tweet donc je la je la mets
entre guillemets. L'avocat de SOS
Méditerranée a dit sur Twitter qu'il
souhaitait que Marine Le Pen disparaisse
au fond de de l'océan. Qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ?
Écoutez pas je je j'ai pas lu le tweet
non plus. Je
il s'appelle votre avocat. Comment ? Ah
si, je je connais notre avocat, il
s'appelle
monsieur Mabi, je crois.
Euh
demande à sourcer.
Voilà, je pense ça serait ça serait
mieux. Euh c'est l'avocat qui c'est une
une autre affaire hein. C'est l'avocat
qui défend un SOS Méditerranée dans le
cadre de l'attaque de nos locaux début
octobre par un groupe. Euh question
internet, il connaît des réseaux de
passeur pour interrogation. Bon, on a
déjà abordé. Est-ce qu'il aide à Est-ce
que vous aidez à les déconstruire
à déconstruire les réseaux de passeur ?
Alors si c'était dans
c'est pas votre rôle
c'est pas notre rôle et c'est pas dans
dans nos capacités. Euh néanmoins dans
le dans le cadre de l'activité en
Méditerranée centrale, euh
il y avait des obligations euh
mises sur tous les navires de sauvetage
par l'État italien un certain nombre de
de règles euh et notamment
qui qui sont des règles de bon sens
hein. Il est hors de question que ce
genre d'embarcation enfin pour n'importe
quel marin que ce genre d'embarcation
criminelle ces bouts de plastique puisse
éventuellement resservir quoi donc ou
que les moteurs qui voilà donc une des
règles par exemple qui a peut-être plus
contribué au fait que de de lutter
contre contre le système c'est de couler
c'est de couler ces de de couler ces
ces esquives criminels. Oui.
Ouais. Question d'internet, pourquoi
n'ont-ils pas voulu accoster en Corse ?
Alors, accoster en Corse, c'était un un
cas particulier.
C'est lorsque l'Aquarius en juin,
j'étais à bord, début juin, a fait ses
sauvetages et on a inauguré
malheureusement la la fermeture des
ports italien et l'aquarius s'est
retrouvé sans port de débarquement euh
alors que son activité a été coordonnée
par le centre de coordination des des
sauvetages de Rome.
Euh le centre des coordinations des
sauvetages de Rome était à la fois en
train de coordonner l'Aquarius et donc
avait techniquement la responsabilité
sur les 630 personnes qui étaient qui
étaient à bord du navire. euh et n'avait
pas la possibilité de désigner ses côtes
comme portarquement pour des parce que
c'était le choix politique italien. Dans
ce cadre-là, ça a pris plusieurs jours
et des pour qu'une solution soit trouvé.
Cette solution a été trouvée en Espagne.
Et je reviens à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure, ce n'est pas l'aarius. Ce n'est
pas le capitaine qui décide qui décide
où il doit débarquer les gens. Ce sont
les États qui lui disaient. Le seule
chose que peut faire le capitaine, c'est
de se c'est de refuser de débarquer les
gens dans un endroit où qui ne
correspond pas à la définition
transcerne de ce qu'est un port sûr. Un
endroit où les gens évidemment vont
avoir vont être à l'abri au sec, avoir à
manger, enfin pouvoir être à l'abri.
Mais un endroit aussi et c'est
clairement dans la définition du de
l'organisation maritime internationale,
un endroit où les personnes secourues ne
seront pas ne risqueront pas d'être
victime de d'abus,
ne risqueront pas être victime de
torture et pourront
accéder à la protection internationale
si si elles en ont besoin. Et c'est sur
ces éléments-l que la Libye ne peut pas
ne peut pas être désignée comme un pors
sûr. Et donc, il est arrivé à quelques
reprises et notamment lors de la
dernière opération de l'Aquarius en
octobre dernier [souffle coupé] que
l'Aquarius se refuse de ramener les gens
ou de contribuer à les transférer vers
une vedette des gardes de côte
libéquence
aurait été de ramener ces personnes
secours
dans les réseaux de corruption et tout
de les ramener en Libye et que la Libye
aujourd'hui c'est c'est dit par tout le
monde y compris par l'Union européenne
dans ces directives de mise en œuvre de
l'opération
de Frontex.
Oui, la Libye ne peut pas être considéré
comme un poréquences de notre
intervention là-bas.
C'est ce que beaucoup disent, beaucoup
analysent. Les humanitaires évitent ce
genre de commentaire.
Par définition, c'est pas notre
intervention ou l'intervention de X Y Z.
Oui, il y a eu une intervention
européenne en Libye et que et oui, c'est
c'est pas très difficile de de voir que
le le l'instabilité libenne date de
cette époque-là. Euh et aujourd'hui,
il y a quelque chose à construire,
quelque chose à construire
diplomatiquement avec la Libye. J'ai pas
du tout la prétention d'avoir les clés
ni même la solution. simplement euh là
aussi il faut que les États européens
euh travail de concert travail de
concert à la fois assume euh assume et
assume aussi sur cet environnement qui
est on parle pas de d'un environnement
lointain, on parle de notre mère euh la
Méditerranée.
Voilà, on pourra parler de de Malte,
mais Malte, la Sicile, la Corse, on
vient d'en parler, tout ça, c'est on est
tous nés là, quoi. le c'est c'est c'est
notre mer et la Libye voilà
il y a des ruines romaines tout le long
de la la de la côte de la côte libienne.
Tout ça c'est notre histoire et c'est
dans ce cadre là que l'Union européenne
pour nous et on l'a toujours interpellé
a une responsabilité. C'est pas juste
des eaux internationales qui par hasard
sont au sud de l'Europe. Non, ce on a
une responsabilité en tant que que
peuple européen globalement à faire en
sorte que nos valeurs soient défendues
en Méditerranée centrale.
On va vous passer une petite vidéo euh
qu'on a été
downloadé sur un
sur une chaîne YouTube. D'ailleurs, une
personne que vous connaissez, votre
président
a fait a fait l'interview et on voudrait
qu'on qu'on l'analyse ensemble. D'accord
les gars, quand vous voulez.
On sait pertinemment que les traversées
vont continuer. On le sait parce que il
y a une pression forte dans les pays
d'origine que ça va pas mieux dans les
pays d'origine, les pays en guerre ou
les pays en crise économique ou quelle
que soi les raisons. Euh donc les gens
vont continuer à partir. De l'autre
côté, l'Europe continue à ériger des
frontières de plus en plus et des
barricades et des et des murs ou des
barbelés et cetera.
Et donc qu'est-ce qui reste pour rentrer
en Europe ? Il reste uniquement les
voies les plus dangereuses et notamment
la mer. Et donc on sait que il va y
avoir des milliers de personnes qui vont
continuer à mettre leur vie en danger
sur la mer pour pouvoir rentrer en
Europe puisqueil y a pas d'autres
alternatives pour rentrer de manière
légale et sécurisée.
Donc il y a pas d'autres alternatives
pour entrer de de manière légale et
sécurisée ?
Euh est-ce que c'est ça créer la la
l'effet d'appel ? C'est-à-dire proposer
de les sauver et ensuite de les faire
rentrer légalement sur le territoire.
C'est il y a pas d'alternative
aujourd'hui, pas suffisamment
et certainement pas de façon coordonnée
entre pays de l'Union européenne. Et
donc ce constat qu' a quelques quelques
temps je crois
le nom de votre présidente
Sophie Beau, directrice générale et
vice-présidente de notre
qui a l'air très fatigué d'ailleurs
mais qui a monté SOS Méditerranée et qui
travaille sans relâche à faire en sorte
que que que l'organisation se développe.
Euh ce constat est toujours vrai
aujourd'hui. Il y a il y a pas de
solution. les Européens ne proposent
rien. Euh et après, c'est pas de la
grande géopolitique que de voir
simplement les Oui. les kilomètres de
murs qui sont construits.
Et et en Méditerranée centrale, c'est
pas des murs, simplement c'est une
volonté manifeste de renforcer les
gardes de côte libre
que de sauver des vies des gens, c'est
c'est c'est pour clairement faire en
sorte que les gens restent de ce côté
sud de la Méditerranée. et ensuite
derrière, il y a pas grandchose qui est
prévu pour pour les aider pour pour
faire en sorte que ça se passe mieux.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est vraiment une
politique délibérée de bloquer et et ce
qui est criminel, on l'a dit parfois, on
l'a répété, [raclement de gorge]
c'est pas les ONG qui sauvent des vies.
Ce qui est criminel, c'est de c'est de
s'acharner à faire des murs de plus en
plus. Plus le mur est haut, plus les
gens vont prendre des dangers
incroyables pour le pour le franchir et
ils vont le franchir en moindre quantité
avec beaucoup plus de morts à la clé. Et
c'est ce qui se passe exactement depuis
plusieurs années en Méditerranée
centrale et c'est de pire en pire. Euh
aujourd'hui, on n'est même pas capable
là en novembre 2018 de même de mesurer
euh le nombre de départs ou le nombre de
personnes qui se noi euh simplement
parce que il y a autre chose que qui qui
se met en place en en criminalisant et
en bloquant le travail des navires de
secours. Euh c'est aussi le témoignage.
C'est-à-dire que il y a plus personne
pour voir en fait, il y a plus de
journalistes. L'Aquarius avait depuis
son départ en février 2016, on a
toujours eu à cœur d'avoir au minimum de
3 qu journalistes à bord sur toutes nos
rotations de différents médias, des
télés, des radios, des on vous a jamais
amené mais vous viendrez un jour. Euh
mais
ce que je veux dire, c'est que on a
toujours c'est c'est pour nous très
important aussi parce que c'est le début
de la solution aussi. c'est c'est
montrer la réalité de ce qui se passe.
Et aujourd'hui, finalement, on arrive à
cette espèce de de brouillard, de flou
où les gens sont à nouveau plus des
gens, mais des chiffres sont des
chiffres de voilà, il y a 600000
personnes en Libye mais je vous dirais 6
millions, je vous dirais 60000 peu
importe tout tout ça n'est pas très
clair et on voit plus cette réalité et
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important aussi de pouvoir témoigner, de
montrer cette réalité pour que elle
reste aigue et que on continue à
considérer qu'il y a un problème en
Méditerranée centrale. Fait checké par
la communauté de Sébastien Mabille. On a
envie de la pousser dans l'océan qu'elle
disparaissait jamais. Et ça date de si
tu peux me descendre la fenêtre. Non,
j'ai pas la date.
Février 2017. Parenthèse fermée. Désolé.
[raclement de gorge] Euh autre question.
Euh aujourd'hui, en préparant euh le en
finissant de préparer votre euh votre
passage chez nous, parce qu'en fait, on
le prépare depuis euh au peut-être 4
mois, 5 mois, même 4 mois, 4 mois, 3
mois, juillet, août, août, septembre,
octobre, novembre. Non,
ça fait un certain temps qu'on le
prépare. On a rencontré quelques
quelquesuns de vos collaborateurs
à Fécan. Une très belle ville, très
sympa. On vous conseille d'aller là-bas,
c'est magnifique. Les gens sont super
sympas.
Aujourd'hui, on m'a envoyé un truc qui
vient juste de sortir, un truc qu'on
connaissait pas, qu'on va finir de
creuser, euh
une caméra cachée d'un d'un infiltré
dans une ONG
euh qui filme une responsable qui
s'appelle Arael Ricker de l'ONG Advocate
Abard euh et qui dit voilà, on entraîne
les migrants à répondre au et à surjouer
pour qu'ils puissent
rentrer en Europe plus facilement.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de ça ? Est-ce que il y a des des bah
des médias training de migrants pour
passer les contrôles ensuite quand ils
arrivent au port ou pour entourel louper
les douanes ?
Alors, j'ai jamais entendu parler de ce
cas-là. Je je sais pas où ça se passe
d'ailleurs. J'amais entendu parler de
cette organisation.
Euh non,
à mon avis, ça va faire beaucoup de
bruit parce que là, ils ont déjà 100000
vues en moins de 24 heures. À mon avis,
ça va faire beaucoup de bruit. Faut se
rendre compte de ce que c'est
l'aquarius.
77 m de long, 600 personnes à bord.
Croyez-moi, je vois mal comment un un
média training ou même un briefing
je me souviens quand quand j'étais à
bord qui était une situation un peu
complexe, on avait des informations
pas évidentes à donner aux gens.
C'est-à-dire que on était pour la
première fois dans cette situation où on
pouvait pas leur leur donner de
d'information sur ce qui allait advenir
d'eux. le on avait pas de solution et et
je me souviens quand on a eu la solution
de Valence qui s'ouvrait pour
l'Aquarius, Valence en Espagne qui qui a
fini par accueillir l'Aquarius, il a
fallu la communiquer aux gens à bord.
C'est quelque chose qui a pris des
heures euh parce qu'il faut pouvoir
parler avec des petits groupes, il faut
pouvoir parler, on avait je sais plus
une dizaine de nationalités, peut-être
plus même à l'époque. Il faut pouvoir le
dire dans plein de langues, il faut
pouvoir passer par Donc c'est c'est
complètement impossible de d'avoir un
briefing. Ce serait impossible d'avoir
un briefing des gens et puis pour leur
dire quoi ? Euh on essayait sur
l'Aquarius avec notre partenaire médecin
sans frontière
d'être le plus humain possible. On
essaie d'être le plus humain possible et
puis aussi de donner des informations
claires et précises.
Surtout surtout que les gens sautent pas
des bateaux en vous voyant arriver en
vous prenant pour la police. Non, vous
les prévenez que vous êtes pas la
police, que vous êtes là pour les sortir
de la merde.
Alors quand on quand on arrive sur un
sauvetage au moment où on approche de
l'embarcation en détresse, il y a tout
un travail qui est extrêmement délicat.
C'est le moment le plus critique qui est
celui de de
gérer les mouvements de panique.
Voilà, de gérer les mouvements de
panique et c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouve dans beaucoup de d'opérations
de sauvetage. C'est c'est le facteur
humain qui va qui va créer le problème
et et [souffle coupé] puis on est sur
des encore une fois sur des
embarcations. On en a vu plus d'une fois
des embarcations se casser devant nos
yeux et là on on a un autre problème qui
est 120 personnes à l'eau dont la
majorité ne sait pas nager. C'est une
c'est une opération critique parfois qui
se solde avec des avec des décès. Donc
gérer la panique et donner une
information claire, précise, calme est
absolument importante. Le message quand
on approche des des bateaux en détresse
a toujours été de leur dire que on était
pas les gardes côte libiens parce que la
peur des gens c'est de revenir en Libye.
Je reviens toujours sur cette situation
en Libye, mais il fuit euh ce que
souvent on a qualifié et que eux-mêmes
qualifient d'en faire. Et on a eu des
exemples où de de de sauvetage très
complexe et un peu tendu où les gardes
de côte libien s'approchaient alors
qu'on était en train de faire un un
sauvetage et où les gens se jettent à
l'eau. Se jettent à l'eau parce que ils
veulent ils ne veulent juste pas être
pris, rattrapés, intercepté par les
gardes de côte libien. Euh et euh ça ça
a même dans des cas qui n'ont pas
concerné l'aquarius mais d'autres
sauvetages. Euh il y a eu des moments où
euh euh une une interférence de garde-
côte libien sur un sauvetage d'une ONG a
fait des morts à la fin euh parce que
les gens euh les gens se sont jetés à
l'eau et et se sont noyés simplement par
peur euh non de ne pas être secouru et
d'être intercepté par les guerres de
côte libien. Donc oui, gérer le calme,
c'est important. Moi je vous parle de la
période où les gens sont à bord
[soupir][souffle coupé]
et il faut leur donner des informations
sur ce qui va advenir d'eux. C'est pas
une information qu'on donne tout de
suite le premier jour parce queon a
souvent des gens qui ont besoin euh
d'énormément de repos, de soin, de
de calme. Euh le premier réflexe, c'est
parfois de dormir pendant 16 17 heures
d'affilé. les gens se se retrouvent sur
un moment euh et souvent ils nous l'ont
dit, c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont en
sécurité et ils se sentent
pas menacé par quoi que ce soit alors
que pourtant c'est un c'est un c'est un
milieu instable, un navire, hein. Et la
la haute mer, c'est quelque chose que
pratiquement personne ne connaît parmi
parmi ces gens. Euh et parfois ils sont
malades, ils ont le mal de mer donc il y
a il y a plein de complexités, ils ont
froid, ils se mais mais quand même ils
nous disent que il ils ont un moment de
respiration quand même sur l'aquarius.
Ça dure que que quelques heures, que
quelques jours, mais ils ont un moment
où enfin ils se sentent euh oui en
sécurité ou en tout cas pas menacés par
quelque chose. Et on leur doit des
informations. Qu'est-ce qui va advenir
d'eux ? Il faut qu'on puisse leur dire
quelque chose. Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
? Ils ont des millions de questions.
Est-ce qu'on va les emmener en Europe ?
Dans quel pays ? Et pourquoi ? comment
ça va se passer et cetera. On a toujours
eu pour comme ligne de condu comme ligne
de conduite pour répondre à votre
question tout à l'heure euh de d'être
extrêmement transparent et de ne dire
que ce dont on était sûr. euh dans le
cadre qui était établi, le cadre de de
débarquement qui était établi avec les
autorités italiennes, on pouvait donner
un certain nombre d'éléments aux
personnes avant qu'elles ne débarquent,
leur dire qu'effectivement au
débarquement, il y aurait telles et
telles organisations présentes que il
fallait pas qu'ils aient peur parce
queils allaient avoir oui un entretien
avec probablement la police et puis
qu'ensuite dans la plupart des cas, ils
seraient emmené vers un vers un centre
d'accueil et que à un moment ils
auraient la possibilité de de de faire
de déposer une demande d'asile ou pas.
Euh et la seule information, c'est pas
un briefing sur ce qu'il faut dire, ce
qu'il faut pas dire, l'information qui a
toujours été donnée sur l'aquarius,
c'est de dire aux gens, racontez votre
histoire de A à Z, dites tout, dites ce
que vous savez, dites et ensuite ensuite
c'est les officiers d'asile qui
détermineront les choses. Mais mais
surtout expliquez bien, expliquez bien
ce qui s'est passé, dites-le bien ce que
vous nous dites à nous, c'est très bien,
mais ça n'a pas vraiment d'importance.
Aucune demande d'asile ne se traite sur
un bateau par définition. Euh donc dites
tout. C'est c'est ça. Euh donc je
connais pas l'histoire de la caméra
cachée. Je sais pas ce qui a été dit et
cetera, mais simplement sur l'aquarius,
c'est de la transparence et simplement
de l'information.
C'est pour ça que vous êtes là.
Voilà.
Comment ça gère à bord ?
J'ai vu que vous séparez les hommes et
les femmes et les enfants.
Oui.
Donc les femmes et les enfants ensemble
et les hommes séparés.
Oui.
Pourquoi ? euh pour prendre un petit peu
au au autant soin que possible des uns
et des autres euh les femmes et les
enfants. Euh des
questions de religion
non non pas du tout euh pour des
questions de vulnérabilité les femmes
les enfants
est-ce que vous avez eu des est-ce que
vous avez eu des cas où euh vous avez
euh des femmes médecins à bord
Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez eu des cas où des
hommes refusaient de se faire osculter
par vos femmes médecins ?
Pas à ma connaissance. Pas à ma
connaissance. l'ensemble des du
passagers de l'aquarius ne passe pas
systématiquement chez le médecin. La
première chose qui est faite, c'est
d'identifier les plus critiques,
les cas les plus critiques et les les
cas qui peuvent être soignés à bord et
de pouvoir suivre les gens. Il y a des
cas urgents euh qui sont pris en charge
tout de suite, voir parfois extrêmement
urgents avec des des des réanimations
voir des réanimations en série après un
un sauvetage. Euh il y a des cas à
surveiller. Je pense notamment aux
femmes enceintes, à des gens qui
auraient des des blessures, des maladies
des maladies chroniques de
l'hypothermie. Il a on a une petite
unité d'hospitalisation à bord de
l'Aquarius. On peut hospit six personnes
euh on six sous six six personnes on
peut hospitaliser six personnes de façon
simultanée. Après, on s'organise si on
doit hospitaliser plus de personnes. En
tout cas, les surveiller sur un
traitement médical.
Euh les les femmes, les enfants, c'est
parce que par définition dans toute
action humanitaire, on on fait
extrêmement euh attention aux
vulnérabilité des femmes et des enfants
et des mineurs isolés euh qui sont tous
susceptibles d'être euh voilà de d'être
embêté, d'être plus fragile, d'être plus
malade. Voilà. Donc on a une attention
particulière évidemment, ça veut pas
dire que les hommes sont pas bien
traités, mais simplement
une coque de 70 m de long, c'est pas si
grand que ça. Et c'est certainement pas,
comme on a pu le lire et c'est
scandaleux, c'est pas une croisière
quoi. C'est c'est un pont en métal avec
des bouts de choses qui dépassent
partout. Euh il faut trouver il faut
trouver quelques un petit coin pour
pouvoir se se mettre sous une couverture
et essayer de dormir. Le bateau Tang.
Voilà, c'est c'est une solution
d'urgence et c'est pour ça que c'était
je reviens à cette à cette rotation de
Valence où on est resté plusieurs jours
en standby et puis les les deux
rotations suivantes. C'est c'est très
dégradant. c'est extrêmement euh de de
faire vivre à des gens qui qui survivent
à un naufrage euh de leur faire vivre
encore cette épreuve là, de rester même
Oui. Toute heure supplémentaire et non
nécessaire. Euh oui, c'est dégradant. Il
faut il faut il faut se rendre compte
que de que les gens sortent d'une
situation absolument critique et et que
l'aquarius est quelque chose qui est
tout à fait temporaire et c'est une
solution d'urgence. Donc les femmes, les
enfants sont dans une zone particulière
de l'aquarius qui est une zone à
l'intérieur du navire alors que les
hommes euh sont euh logés, si on peut
dire comme ça, en tout cas sont
transportés sur le pont.
Euh
j'ai beaucoup de questions encore
à tout le temps.
Et euh on voit un mini bout de pied,
désolé.
Alors question d'internet. Selon vous,
bon, je sais pas si ça a beaucoup de
rapport avec euh ce qu'on ce qu'on
traite, mais on va la poser comment
quand même. Selon vous, quelles sont les
motivations qui ont pousser BHL à siger
dans le dossier libien ? À simisser dans
le dossier libien ?
Aucune idée.
Voilà.
Désolé.
Bon, c'est réglé. On va en faire deux
trois comme ça. Euh, a-t-il déjà été
menacé physiquement, virtuellement à
cause de son action ? Et là, on peut
parler de l'invasion de vos bureaux
[grognement] euh par les identitaires.
Alors euh physiquement euh alors j'ai
j'étais pas au bureau des SOS Mé
personnellement
au bureau des SOS Méditerrané le jour où
on a eu l'attaque des des identitaires
le 6 le 5 octobre dernier. J'étais sur
le navire pas très loin. Euh j'ai pu
voir l'équipe juste après l'intervention
de de la police à Marseille.
Oui, SOS Méditerranéen a été attaqué euh
physiquement dans ses locaux, dans son
dans son voilà dans son cadre de
travail, dans son intimité
euh euh par ce groupe. Et donc c'est
dans ce cadre là que que voilà que la
police est intervenue, les gens ont été
arrêtés, on a porté plainte et c'est
c'est c'est une histoire qui voilà qui
suit son cours. On est tous
combien de personnes ?
22 à ma connaissance sont rentrés chez
vous.
Sont rentré Oui, 22 personnes sont
rentrées, ça j'en suis sûr. Sont rentré.
dans les locaux de des SOS Méditerrané
euh et 22 ont été interpellés. Je pense
que 22 sont poursuivis. Je j'ai pas de
certitude sur le nombre de personnes qui
ont été poursuivies ensuite par le par
le par le juge. Euh
est-ce qu'on est attaqué, menacé ?
J'ai il y a plein d'histoires au sein
des SOS Méditerranée de plein de
collègues.
Au minimum
tout le monde a eu un des insultes sur
son compte Facebook.
C'est déjà une attaque hein. C'est déjà
c'est déjà quelque chose qui est qui est
relativement fort. Et donc euh euh
oui euh notre compte Facebook, notre
compte Twitter et en général un chapelet
de voilà de commentaires plus ou moins
plus ou moins euh
euh haineux et assez violent, assez
insultant. Heureusement compensé par
aussi euh un certain nombre de
commentaires de gens qui soutiennent
l'action et qui soutiennent le principe
euh
le principe de l'assistance à personne
en danger parce que on parle que de ça
grosso modo chez SOS Méditerranée. C'est
ça qui sont en train de boire la tasse
quand même.
Voilà. Euh et c'est ce qu'on a toujours
dit la question encore une fois hein.
Est-ce qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut pas
? Est-ce qu'il faudrait que ces gens
traversent ne traversent pas ?
On s'en fout. Il faut ces gens sont en
train de se noyer et la première des
choses à faire c'est de les sortir de
l'eau. Toutes les autres questions, on a
tout à fait le droit de les poser après
à terre dans des conditions acceptables,
humaines, dignes. Et et c'est c'est ce
que c'est ce que fait l'aquarius comme
ce que font tous les marins depuis
maintenant des dizaines d'années. Voilà,
euh on a ce ce ce dialogue, si on peut
appeler ça un dialogue, ce disons que
cette suite de monologue comme
commentaire sur nos comptes Facebook et
Twitter. Euh des gens qui soutiennent le
principe, des gens qui euh nous accusent
de de tous les mots, c'est pas vraiment
un dialogue. Euh
est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé
d'organiser un dialogue calme ? Est-ce
que vous avez déjà essayé de les emmener
sur le bateau pour voir ce qui se passe
? On essae, on essaie d'être pédagogue,
d'expliquer euh
est-ce que vous leur avez proposé de
venir avec vous ?
On n'a pas proposé à des individus euh
qui se présente sous
avec une un a priori d'insulte euh on va
dire ou un a priori de de relais de colp
portage de fake news. Euh on leur a pas
proposé de de venir voir par eux-même.
En revanche, SOS Méditerran parce que
d'abord c'est compliqué, ça serait
compliqué, ce serait pas inimaginable.
On en a souvent discuté, hein. Euh SOS
Méditerranée, ce que nous faisons par
contre euh et euh c'est peut-être la
fraîcheur de d'une organisation qui qui
a 2 3 ans, donc toute jeune, d'une
organisation qui est foncièrement
humanitaire, hein, comme toutes les
autres. Euh sa fraîcheur, c'est que on
reste euh et et c'est une ligne
directrice qu'on a voulu garder depuis
le début. Euh on reste extrêmement
inscrit dans la société civile et on
pense que on est né comme ça. On est né
personnes sur un coin de table à la fin
du repas qu' ont décidé de dire tiens et
si on faisait si on essayait de faire
quelque chose ? Oui, il y a eu ça mais
il y a eu aussi ça ça n'aurait pas été
possible s'il y avait pas eu un soutien
assez massif dès le départ de personnes
qui ont de toutes les strates de la
société, des gens de droite, de gauche,
du milieu qui qui se disent non, on peut
pas laisser des gens se noyer. Et ce
mouvement depuis le début, il est
européen, multiforme, de nombreuses
personnes et de la société civile. Et
ça, on s'est dit que c'est une richesse
qu'on voulait absolument gens du Front
National qui vous soutiennent.
Alors euh on demande pas aux gens leur
leurs affiliations politiques.
Vous votez vous ?
Je vote. Oui.
Vous votez quoi ?
J'ai beaucoup de mal à voter. J'ai
beaucoup de mal à voter parce que je me
force à voter euh parce que je pense que
c'est un devoir. Euh enfin je le
considère moi comme un devoir. Euh j'ai
comme une obligation. comme une
obligation comme aussi
se ne pas s'exprimer d'une faç même si
elle c'est une façon euh qui qui est pas
qui qui est pas satisfaisante
euh ne pas s'exprimer c'est s'interdire
aussi euh c'est de c'est c'est pas se
donner voilà c'est pas pas rentrer dans
le dans dans dans le débat et je me
force à à ne pas échapper au débat on va
dire de par cette façon-là si je dis que
j'ai du mal à voter c'est que j'ai du
mal à trouver euh aujourd'hui dans le
paysage politique français mais européen
plus généralement
euh des discours qui soient porteur de
d'alternative, qui soi porteur de qui
soit porteur de de d'histoires
positives, d'histoires narratives. Je
vois beaucoup de négatif euh et je vois
beaucoup de critiques et beaucoup de
c'est c'est c'est je suis peut-être pas
le mieux placé pour le commenter, mais
je vois beaucoup de de de court terme et
de et de vision à court terme. que euh
et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui tue d'une
certaine façon, je trouve, hein,
l'implication politique et le le goût de
la chose politique chez chez les
Européens en particulier et qui amène à
des situations aujourd'hui euh tel qu'on
les vit aujourd'hui de de clivage
extrême sur des sujets.
On parle de personnes qui se noient, on
parle de j'aime pas utiliser le mot,
mais on parle de valeur, on parle de
principes. Est-ce que ça viendrait à
l'idée de qui que ce soit les gens du
Front National inclus ? Et je ne le
pense pas, ces gens-là, je pense
quand ils sont témoins d'un accident de
la route, ils arrêtent leur voiture, ils
vont donner un coup de main et c'est
naturel et heureusement qu'ils le font.
Euh donc il y a aucune différence. C'est
juste quelque chose qui est fait à plus
grande échelle et dans un principe aussi
de de de ce qui a cimenté grosso modo la
façon de vivre ensemble en Europe. Et et
c'est quelque chose que je ne me rés pas
à à avoir dénigré et avoir ignoré parce
que il y a ceux qui dénigrent et puis il
y a ceux qui disent rien et cela je leur
en veux beaucoup aussi dans dans les
hommes politiques. On le voit
aujourd'hui.
Alors les hommes politiques les je veux
pas vous les citer mais tous ceux qui
noms
le pavillon de l'aquarius sont il y a il
y a plus d'un mois on on essaie de poser
sur la table de façon assez respectueuse
on explique que voilà bon là c'est assez
manifeste on veut nous empêcher
d'opérer.
C'est illégal c'est pour plein de
raisons. Nous on n' pas le temps de de
creuser la question de est-ce que c'est
légal ou pas. Ce qu'on veut c'est
repartir en mer.
C'est euh pouvoir être là euh alors
qu'il y a pas d'autres navires ou très
peu. Euh on fait un appel assez
manifeste. Euh pour la première fois
dans l'existence de SOS Méditerranée, on
reprend comme au premier jour les
citoyens à témoin. On a demandé aux gens
de descendre dans les rues. On
on génère un mouvement
assez important de de personnes qui
descendent dans les rues de Marseille,
de Berlin.
Oui, plus de 40000 personnes au total.
euh plus de 40000 personnes au total
dans en France, mais surtout plus d'une
soixantaine de villes au total, des
petits groupes, des des des gros groupes
à Marseille. Bref,
40000 en tout.
Non, plus que 40000 en tout. Euh, on a
combien ?
On plus le chiffre en tête. On a
100000 1 million.
Non, entre 40000 et 100000. 80000 je
pense. Euh on fait des communiqués de
presse précis. Euh, on appelle les États
européens à faire quelque chose, on a on
appelle les États du monde à se
mobiliser pour l'aquarius, à le faire,
même s'ils sont pas d'accord. Et je peux
comprendre que la politique migratoire,
ce soit des débats compliqués, que
électoralement ce soit des débats
compliqués. Simplement la sauvegarde de
la vie imide, c'est pas un débat
compliqué. Et même si on n'est pas
d'accord, on doit avoir pour principe,
on doit comprendre qu'un navire tel que
l'Aquarius doit exister.
Donc j'
Voilà, c'était il y a un mois,
pardon. Mais je reviens juste sur la sur
la question. C'était il y a un mois et
et aujourd'hui il y a pas grand-chose,
il y a pas grand monde qui se bouge
et ça arrange un peu tout le monde que
l'Aquarius soit hacké à Marseille et que
finalement [soupir]
il y a un témoin gênant en moins. Il y a
on en parle moins et puis finalement je
sais plus quel commentateur disait
l'autre jour et a raison dans un que
finalement un problème dont on ne parle
plus c'est un problème qui n'existe
plus. euh
euh et tous ces gens-là qui étaient déjà
extrêmement anonymes euh n'existe plus.
Donc c'est
et et ça je peux pas m'y résoudre et
j'en je je je trouve que les gens qui ne
se positionnent pas, les politiques qui
qui qui n'essayent pas de montrer de de
construire un projet alternatif au
projet d'exclusion qu'on voit
aujourd'hui, ils sont coupables. Oui,
ils sont coupables de pas essayer et je
ne prétends pas trouver la solution mais
de ne pas essayer de réinsuffler un
une base. Il y a une ligne rouge qu'on
peut pas franchir et la ligne rouge,
c'est les valeurs et on est en train de
la franchir. on est en train de franchir
cette ligne rouge et de dire bah non
finalement quelqu'un qui se noie
quelqu'un sur le bord du de la route
c'est pas si grave
la fin la fin justifie les moyens et ça
c'est quelque chose de qu'on peut pas
laisser passer et que contre lequel on
va continuer à se battre avec énormément
de détermination.
Vous êtes croyant
non ?
Les les gens qui sont dans votre
organisation sont croyants ?
Il y en a Oui.
De quel type de confession ? Il y a des
catholiques.
Euh je demande rarement aux gens leur
leur confession et puis il la gardent
pour eux. Je je sais qu'il y a des gens
qui que qui ont une comment dire un
voilà une foi importante catholique.
Oui.
C'est un peu les fondements du
catholicisme des prochains.
Oui. Euh on a eu on a eu des des signes
de reconnaissance parfois de de l'
Vatican. Le Vatican vous a aidé. On
aurait aimé pour l'instant. On n pas eu
un pavillon du Vatican, c'est quelque
chose qui est peu probable parce que
c'est techniquement quasiment
impossible. Le Vatican a un registre euh
mais n'a pas de navire immatriculé
depuis très longtemps. Donc il y a pas
toute la l'infrastructure pour
enregistrer un navire. Euh à un moment,
on l'a évoqué simplement parce que en
terme de de valeur, c'est quelque chose
Oui. qui aurait pu être envisagé. Vous
avez le vous avez le 0,6 du pape.
J'ai pas le 06 du pape, mais si vous
l'avez, je le veux bien. Non, nous on a
le 06 du cardinal noir.
Ah
euh donc là, on en arrive. Je vais je
vais faire un petit package euh de
questions, mais en fait c'est pas un
package, c'est
établir le
On va on va faire une question à tiroir.
D'accord.
Donc je je reprends mes notes. Le
principe le plus ancien du droit
maritime, c'estàd sauver les gens
versus le principe de la guerre
économique.
À votre avis, qui est-ce qui gagne ?
C'est ce que je disais à l'instant. Moi,
je me bat pour que ce soit le principe
[raclement de gorge]
le le principe d'assistance à personne
en danger qui qui gagne. Euh mais
aujourd'hui effectivement euh
l'attaque de ce droit maritime de de de
cette ce morceau-là du droit maritime he
qui est qui est vraiment très très
simple he et très basique l'obligation
d'assistance
montre que
montre que oui il semblerait que la fin
justifie les moyens euh et que les
moyens qu'il y a pas de limite aux
moyens euh et pourtant c'est tout ce qui
a été construit par euh bah pas tout ce
ces conventions internationales.
Euh
c'est un vernis,
moi ça me fait enfin
c'est un vernis qui saute avec
l'évolution du climat, c'estàdire les
les il y aura des millions de de ça
continue d'ailleurs des millions de
réfugiés climatiques qui vont se mettre
en route de plus en plus avec le l'effet
du réchauffement climatique. Est-ce que
est-ce que vous anticipez quel type de
de d'anticipation de prospective vous
avez sur votre activité d'humanitaire ?
Ça va aller de mieux en mieux, de pire
en pire.
Ça va être de
droit maritime va sauter.
Le droit maritime va sauter.
On va vous couler comme le Rainbow
Warrior.
Nous, on sera là pour faire en sorte que
le le droit maritime soit soit défendu
et on s'est parfois posé la question de
de savoir si voilà comment on pouvait
renforcer encore ce ce
on fait du lobbing,
ce droit maritime. On essaie de lobbying
c'est un grand mot mais on essaie de
d'être pédagogue déjà d'essayer
d'expliquer comment ça marche d'essayer
de de couper l'herbe sous le pied des
des interprétation un peu trop simpliste
du type le le pool factor ou ce genre de
chos d'essayer de de montrer la
complexité des choses de dire aussi que
tout tout n'est Ouais voilà on essaie
d'être pédagogue et on essaie de
sensibiliser aussi on essaie aussi de
donner une espèce de de d'humanité de de
de de ramener l'humanité dans tout ça
parce que euh parce que c'est trop
facile de de lire des chiffres, de lire
des voilà de de voir à travers ces
mouvements des phénomènes, des dizaines
de milliers de de vous dites de de
personnes qui qui partiront dans le
futur. Oui, à la fin c'est des histoires
individuelles, c'est c'est des
individus. On essaie de ramener ça aussi
pour ramener aussi euh les choses à leur
juste place et de ramener aussi la
l'importance de de la vie de de de la
sauvegarde de la vie comme étant quand
même une priorité. a priori, c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on est tous
d'accord euh euh et donc mais qu'il faut
défendre. Donc c'est c'est ce qu'on
ramène tout le temps. Alors après la la
perspective de pour les humanitaires
dans le futur, c'est un petit peu une
question de tiroir. Oui effectivement
ce que je pressens c'est que les choses,
je sais pas si elles seront
[grognement]
les choses vont être de plus en plus euh
clivantes, clivée euh voire violente.
Euh et je crois que civil
Ah ça je le saurais pas dire mais
simplement je je pense que je suis très
impressionné. Euh je vous disais ça fait
un peu moins de 20 ans que que je
travaille dans l'humanitaire. J'ai j'ai
côtoyé quelques régimes
euh qui étaiit pas du des grands états
de droit, on va dire. Euh le Soudan euh
les plus belles plongées sont à faire au
Soudan.
Voilà. mais des gens qui qui
manifestement euh utilisaient la force
de de leur état pour bloquer les
humanitaires. C'est pas une histoire
nouvelle, on en parlait en début
d'entretien. Euh ça fait 6 mois que je
je travaille sur la question de la
Méditerranée centrale avec l'aquarius et
je suis impressionné par euh
par la puissance qui peut être m qui
peut être mise en opposition à des
toutes petites organisations telles que
la nôtre. euh empêcher les grandes tour
alors que nous ne sommes qu'un petit
bateau certes vaillant mais un petit
bateau de 77 m une poignée de personne
qui essayons simplement de de faire au
mieux à la place des États parce queon
essaie aussi de pousser les États. Vous
parliez de lobbying ? Oui, on essaie de
la société civile qui
voilà, on essaie de de dire et c'est
impressionnant de voir à quel point on
est les la criminalisation globalement
mais nos collègues d'autres
organisations sociales ou humanitaires
qui travaillent qui travaillent dans
l'accueil, qui travaillent dans dans
plein d'autres questions en France le
vivent aussi hein et en témoigne. Voilà,
je suis assez impressionné et donc
effectivement c'est un petit peu
inquiétant toute cette toute cette force
qui est mise à l'encontre des ONG
et on essaie de se défendre aujourd'hui
par le
droit. C'est inquiétant. C'est
inquiétant parce que vous comprenez pas
la situation.
Non,
c'est inquiétant parce qu'on on a encore
foi dans le droit et dans les règles
telles qu'elles ont été établies et
telles qu'elles sont de façade toujours
euh elles sont toujours en pratique ces
règles
de façade
de façade parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que voilà, on
instrumentalise et on nous retourne
parfois le droit maritime, on nous dit
"Ah oui, le captaine a a obligation de
coordonner." Et donc comme il a
obligation de coordonner, alors euh
puisqu'il coordonne avec les Libys,
alors il a obligation d'obéir aux
libiens, même quand les Libyens donnent
un ordre illégal. Enfin, on nous
retourne toute cette toute cette logique
là et et la logique du droit maritime,
c'est euh les capitaines doivent faire
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour secourir les
gens en mer et les États doivent faire
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour faciliter la
vie du capitaine. C'est pas plus
compliqué que ça. Euh dans dans le
respect de la dignité et de du droit à
protection des des
Est-ce que vous mettez à la place des
dirigeants ?
Oui, parfois.
Quel Quel est leur biotope ? Ils
évoluent dans quel type de biotope ? On
on va on va commencer à l'échelle macro.
D'accord.
Pour vous, ils évoluent dans quel type
de biotop ?
Bah, ils évoluent dans un dans un monde
où je pense il manque de parfois de
de témoignag et de et de de concret. Je
pense qu'il ne se rendent plus compte de
Ils ont pas du tout de service de
renseignement qui les tient au courant.
Ils ont pas du tout de satellite qui
regardent un peu partout. Ils ont pas du
tout de bateau dans la région. Ils ont
pas du tout d'avion dans la région. Ils
savent pas du tout combien il y a de
personnes sur les routes avec les
téléphones portables. Ils savent pas du
tout ça.
Ah si, probablement ils savent tout ça.
Oui.
Donc ils savent pertinemment de ce qui
se passe.
Oui.
Oui. Donc
simplement ils le savent. Ils le savent
de façon analytique des beaux
graphiques, des cartes, des analyses. Il
le voit.
Il parle de flux de de tendance de et
cetera.
On voit pas les gens derrière.
Euh et à chaque fois qu'on a eu
l'occasion, vous me demandiez si on
mettait nos détracteurs en face à cette
réalité, c'est pas facile. Mais on on
essaie de d'aller au devant des gens. On
est dans présent dans en France en
particulier dans plein d'événements. On
essaie de de croiser plein de monde et
parfois des gens qui voilà qui qui
posent les mêmes questions. Et est-ce
que vous êtes pas un peu finalement
Non mais c'est ça. Est-ce que vous êtes
pas un peu une partie du problème et
cetera ? Et on se rend compte que à
chaque fois qu'on prend le temps et
merci euh de ici on a le temps aussi, à
chaque fois qu'on prend le temps,
on arrive petit à petit à ramener cette
humanité et à ramener cette et et voilà.
Euh on s'est posé la question pour nos
nos dirigeants de se dire "Est-ce qu'il
faut pas les embarquer aussi un jour ?"
Euh voilà.
Non, ils voudront pas. Je sais. Nous
nous on veut bien.
C'estd que si vous proposez et je
demande à mes collègues
nous on vient
euh [gémissement]
donc trouvez-nous de la place
et un pavillon d'abord.
Et un pavillon sinon on se débrouillera.
On fera un pavillon avec une tête de
mort.
Et euh revenons à nos moutons.
Le biotope des hommes politiques. Vous
faites pas de géopolitique, vous faites
pas de géostratégie, vous vous regardez
pas le cours du dollar, le cours du
baril de pétrole. Vous regardez pas tout
ça. Vous si j'ai bien compris après 1h30
de discussion, vous pâiez au plus urgent
pour sortir des gens qui boivent la
tasse. Je résume ça trivialement
mais c'est c'est aussi simple que ça.
Donc le biotope des hommes politiques,
réchauffement climatique,
des millions de personnes qui vont se
mettre en branle,
crise économique mondiale avec un
système économique qui est à bout de
souffle,
crise monétaire
et j' et j'en passe des meilleurs.
Épuisement du biotop, épuisement des
ressources, empoisonnement des sols et
la liste est longue comme le bras. Nous,
on traite ça à longueur d'année euh
depuis 6 ans sur cette chaîne YouTube.
Euh euh mettez-vous à la place des des
hommes politiques. Ils savent qu'ils
sont au pied du mur parce que ils ont
pas fait le travail depuis des années de
stabiliser le monde, d'apporter la paix,
la démocratie pour les petites filles et
on en passait les meilleurs. Et là, il
se retrouve avec des mouvements
populistes qui réagissent de façon
épidermique et symptomatique.
C'est peut-être un peu trop tard pour
être bougé. Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Il y a des salvinies des 5 étoiles,
ils réagissent symptomatiquement.
Ouais.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? C'est quoi
les solutions pour crever l'abscès et
que le dialogue entre hommes, entre les
hommes puisse se faire ? Des des
solutions, des pistes. Je sais pas si je
me suis exprimé
correctement. Oui. Non, mais je je je me
pose les mêmes questions et je je
voilà, on sort les gens qui boivent la
tasse et on n pas les solutions à tout
ça, mais on voit le on voit la même la
même tendance. Bien pire. C'est bien
pire que ça. D'accord. C'est résumé
trivialement
mais c'est pire.
Euh mais la question c'est
je l'apprends à l'envers. Est-ce que
c'est en construisant des murs de plus
en plus haut que on va aller vers une
solution sachant que l'histoire et c'est
c'est c'est utile de revenir vers
l'histoire. On sait que ces murs ont
jamais jamais jamais jamais empêché euh
ces mouvements. Euh et donc il faut
il faut essayer de prendre le problème
par un autre côté, un côté beaucoup plus
politique. Oui, ça n'a pas été fait
depuis des années. Et alors, est-ce
qu'il faut vous perdre espoir dans le
fait que les hommes politiques se se
saisissent du sujet, que de la
diplomatie soit faite, que de du
développement soit fait et que et que
cette question soit revue à travers non
pas un prisme d'intérêt mais à travers
d'un prisme de d'humanité
d'humanité. Oui, un prisme à long terme,
même si on est aux abois, même si le
réchauffement climatique, mais il faut
regarder ça à travers un prisme à long
terme parce que si on ne le fait pas
comme ça, alors on le fait de façon
déshumanisée. Et si on le fait de façon
déshumanisée, alors
la solution la oui, la solution
sera pas bonne. C'est ce que nous
apprend l'histoire aussi. Et c'est pour
ça que
c'est très simple, c'est voir simpliste,
mais euh
ramener cette valeur de la vie humaine.
Enfin, redire quelque chose d'aussi
simple que de dire que c'est
inacceptable et que ce on doit se lever
et se se mobiliser pour faire en sorte
que cette ligne rouge là pour le secours
en mer, mais ça pourra être vrai pour
autre chose demain, que cette ligne
rouge-là ne peut pas être franchie parce
que si on perd ça, alors tout le reste
s'écroule. de ce qui a été construit.
Euh moi, j'y crois vraiment. Il faut
vraiment que cette valeur là de de
l'assistance à autrui euh on on peut pas
la perdre, on peut pas la minimiser, on
peut pas lui donner moins d'importance,
on peut pas la conditionner à d'autres
considérations politiques. Euh et il
faut que
les États fassent de la réal politique.
C'est pas nouveau et ça continuera
simplement dans nos pays et en Europe en
particulier. Il y a toujours eu une
société civile et elle est là avec SOS
Méditerranée, elle est là avec d'autres
organisations. On n'est pas la seule
organisation, on est plusieurs
organisations de sauvetage. Cette
société civile doit continuer à dire,
comme elle l'a dit d'ailleurs le 6
octobre dans les rues, doit continuer à
dire il y a cette limite et nous on ne
suit pas sur certaines valeurs.
Et vous êtes prêt à aller jusqu'où ?
Mettre un drapeau noir avec un crâne
dessus.
On trouvera des solutions. C'est
l'intérêt deêre comme
[raclement de gorge] Paul Watson
aller jusqu'au bout.
on est prêt à aller loin parce que quoi
loin ? On est prêt à trouver toutes les
solutions, même les plus compliquées euh
pour pouvoir être présent en mer et pour
pouvoir continuer à travailler en mer.
Et ça l'ensemble des équipes notamment
les les équipes qui sont à bord sont
extrêmement déterminées à trouver une
solution pour repartir en mer. On a
c'est drôle parce que aujourd'hui il y a
pas beaucoup de solutions qui se
dessinent. Il y a mais
il y a une espèce de conviction qui est
basée sur pas grand-chose que la
solution elle va arriver. C'est on on
n'envisage pas qu'il n'y ait pas de
solution pour l'aquarius. On n'envisage
pas que SOS Méditerranée ne puisse pas
continuer à travailler en mer. Euh et
c'est quelque chose qui est voilà, on
est extrêmement déterminé et les
solutions c'est c'est la force de la
société civile, c'est on va les on va
les inventer euh
on n'est pas sur BFM là le Vous êtes
prêt à faire une greffe de la fin ?
Faire une greffe de la fin, est-ce que
ça aurait un moyen de convaincre ?
Est-ce que ça permettrait de convaincre
?
Si il y a tout un équipage
occidental
qui se met à crever sur son bateau parce
qu'ils font une grève de la fin,
on en est pas à ces solutions là.
Pourquoi ?
Mais bah parce que simplement on essaie
d'être constructif et de construire.
C'est pas constructif ça.
Non, c'est pas très constructif. Non.
Gandy quand il faisait ses grves de la
fin, c'était pas constructif. Si, bien
entendu.
Alors
alors je pense que on n'est pas dans on
est on n'est pas automatiquement dans
dans ce cadre là pour le moment. Mais
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à aller jusque
là ?
Je peux pas vous le dire aujourd'hui et
puis c'est pas moi. C'est une réponse
communiquant ça.
Non mais vraiment je pour communiquant.
C'est pas c'est
c'est pas c'est pas moi moi une crive de
la fin. Peut-être peut-être un jour euh
j'en sais rien. Aujourd'hui, ce qui est
sûr, c'est qu'il faut
faut rester optimiste quand même. Il y a
il y a les ressources euh dans cette
société civile, c'est pas optimiste. Une
grve de la fin. Euh non, parce que c'est
un petit peu le dernier recours, c'est
un petit peu le le truc
absol je pense qu'il y a encore l'espace
pour rappeler et pour faire entendre
cette question de valeur et cette
question de de devoir d'assistance.
Je suis
question pessimiste. C'est pas je suis
pas pessimiste, je suis pragmatique et
factuel.
comprendre quelqu'un qui traverse les
frontières quand il a le ventre vide.
Si vous avez pas expérimenté 3 semaines
sans bouffer, vous comprenez pas son
état psychologique.
J'ai j'ai très peu rencontré
d'humanitaire
qui s'était mis en greffe de la fin
forcée pour comprendre la psychologie
des migrants.
Il faut comprendre jusqu'où eux sont
capables d'aller et nous on voudrait
comprendre jusqu'où vous êtes capable
d'aller.
C'est là la question. Et et là la
réponse
Oui, je
c'est un peu
Oui, c'est pas on est on
est déterminé en tout cas. C'est c'est
évident, on est déterminé.
En tout cas, vous avez des actions qui
qui sauvent l'honneur. Question
d'internet. Euh, avez-vous connaissance
d'entreprise d'entreprise privées qui
tire un intérêt financier cette
situation entre parenthèses en Libye ou
ailleurs au dépend des migrants ? Centre
de détention privée, milice privée et
des noms.
Centre de détention
privé, euh centre de détention illégaux,
euh
clandestin,
euh avec plein de formes de de qui qui
qui permettent de de d'emprisonner des
gens pour les les forcer à travailler
dans l'agriculture de Oui, localement
euh il y en a pas mal. celui qui fait
des tentes ou des choses comme ça. Non.
Alors après les il y a il y a il y a ces
entreprises qui fabriquent les les les
bouts de plastique. Euh
elles sont euh elles ont été euh
régulièrement euh
elles sont traquées par l'Union
européenne dans dans la lutte contre
contre le bah contre le trafic. Euh
aujourd'hui, c'est voilà
ça renaît et il y a régulièrement euh il
y a voilà, on a il y a toujours eu ces
ces bouts de plastique et et euh voilà
parce que a priori elle elle semble
assez insais ces entreprises qui
fabriquent ces ces ces engins de mort là
de ces ces ces rubberat que que voilà
vous on montrait pas dessus. on montrait
pas dessus même au milieu d'une d'une
piscine. Euh
d'autres entreprises qui tireraient
profit cette situation ? Euh euh
non, j'ai pas connaissance en Libye des
individus certainement. Et
la question que je me pose sans en avoir
la
C'est voilà, c'est une question, c'est
que plus
on rend
les traversées compliquées ou
difficiles, plus on essaie de bloquer et
de plus construire ce fameux mur dont on
parlait. Euh
la question, c'est où va-ton le
construire ? Oui. Alors, en Libye c'est
pas tellement ça, mais enfin plus on
essaie de bloquer en et en Libye la
tactique européenne c'est de renforcer
euh les gardes de côte lib, leur donner
plus de moyens, les entraîner, faire en
sorte que ils interceptent les gens.
Voilà. Euh
mais plus on fait ça
euh plus on en fait on alimente d'une
certaine façon et on enrichit. Euh j'ai
pas de de chiffre, mais je suis
absolument certain que cette politique
euh fait probablement euh des
millionnaires parmi parmi les les
trafiquants euh les trafiquants qui
finalement euh avant euh extorquait ou
trafiquer ou euh faisait le le travail
de de passeur pour pour mettre les gens
mettre les gens à l'eau pour les envoyer
les les envoyer en Méditerranée et qui
aujourd'hui le font deux trois quatre
fois pour la même personne parce que la
personne se fait intercepter et repart
dans le système et renvoyer. On a eu
plusieurs fois depuis depuis maintenant
une bonne année sur l'Aquarius. On a eu
souvent des témoignages de gens qui nous
racontaient les une, deux ou trois fois
euh où ils avaient déjà tenté la
traversé, avait déjà été intercepté,
était déjà avait été renvoyé dans dans
le système de détention officielle puis
avait été exfiltré plus ou moins dans un
système parce que tout ça est poureux
dans le système de détention non
officielle. de là euh avait été victime
d'abus, de torture et cetera et et et la
chaîne recommence et on exploité à
nouveau, extorquer à nouveau et renvoyer
sur sur la mer.
Est-ce que vous voulez aborder quelque
chose qu'on aurait oublié ?
Ben, on n pas trop parlé
on n pas trop parlé des gens. Euh enfin
si on a parlé des gens mais on n' pas
trop parlé de la situation aujourd'hui
quand même. Euh aujourd'hui euh
des gens traversent toujours. Euh il y a
grosso modo plus de bateaux d'ONG.
Alors euh l'Aquarius était là jusque
par intermittance ces derniers mois avec
les enjeux de pavillon. L'aquarius était
là jusqu'à début octobre.
une autre ONG italienne s'est créée en
en cours de route essaie de de de faire
au moins un suivi si euh Méditerranéen
euh a frité un un un navire, on espère.
Nous, on a toujours demandé à ce qui est
de plus plus de navire. Euh
mais c'est extrêmement faible, même à
l'époque où 10 navires d'ONG était là au
côté de
5 6 7 navires de la guerre de côte
italienne en permanence des navires
militaires européens. Même à cette
époque-là, on disait que la zone dans
laquelle on trouve des embarcations et
détresses est si large qu'il faudrait
déjà plus et qu'il faudrait encore plus
de navire. Donc aujourd'hui, je il y a
pratiquement plus de navire de
sauvetage.
Euh et non seulement on sait pas ce
qu'il a devient des gens, on sait même
plus s'il y a des des départs et des et
et des naufrages et surtout se dire
qu'il y a plus de départ. Euh
méfions-nous de ce genre d'information
parce que euh personne n'est là pour le
vérifier aujourd'hui pour savoir s'il y
a eu des départs, s'il y a eu des
sauvetages euh et comme c'est compliqué
euh à terre en Libye, il y a même plus
toujours automatiquement des témoins au
moment du
Et celui qui a qui a les yeux dans
l'espace sur la Libye, il le voit quand
même, non ?
Il voit euh il voit peut-être pas les
départs de chacun des canaux. Et s'il
les voit, en tout cas, ces chiffres là,
on les a pas nous. Et en tout voilà,
croire que parce qu'il y a plus d'images
ou parce qu'il y a plus de sauvetage ou
qu'il y a plus de débarquement sur les
côtes européennes, il y a plus de
problème. Ça c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est complètement faux. Voilà, donc
ces navires là sont importants et mais
les ONG depuis elles sont toutes
récentes c'est ces ONG qui qui palient
au travail des des États.
Il y a une solidarité entre les ONG. On
discute, on se coordonne, on essaie de à
l'époque où tout le monde arrivait
encore à avoir accès à la mer, on
essayait de même de se coordonner sur
sur les zones dans lesquelles voilà pas
patrouiller dans les mêmes zones parce
qu'effectivement pour multiplier les
chances de pouvoir secourir des
embarcations et pouvoir la zone la zone
de recherche de Méditerranée centrale
est très très étendue.
Euh on dialogue aussi aujourd'hui sur
toutes les questions de criminalisation
parce que l'Aquarius est bloqué pour des
questions de pavillon mais euh le
Lifeline a été bloqué à Malte jusqu'à
récemment, le Seawat a été bloqué,
l'Open Arms a eu des problèmes en Italie
euh voilà tous les navires par un biais
ou par un autre ont été bloqués,
embêtés.
Je vous une parenthèse. Quand quand on
voit des opérations, je mets entre
guillemets d'identitaire
ou
à frêter des bateaux.
Oui.
Pour contrecarrer vos opérations.
Il y a eu cet épisode en 2017
effectivement avec le C Star euh qui
était là pour contrecarrer les
interventions. Bon, ça a été plutôt un
un échec
un échec un échec maritime aussi et en
terme de navigation. Euh
aujourd'hui, c'est Oui, on a eu à
plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs moments
sur des débarquement des manifestations
hostiles euh des banderoles déployés, ce
genre de choses. Euh c'est essayer de
nous faire rentrer dans un débat qui
n'est pas le nôtre. En fait le nôtre, il
est pas de savoir euh est-ce qu'on doit
euh est-ce que le nôtre il est juste de
dire on a secouru des gens et on on suit
le droit maritime, on les débarque à
terre. On les débarque à terre dans un
port sû, c'est-à-dire un endroit où ils
ont accès à la protection et cetera et
cetera.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview
déjà.
Bah ça fait 1h52 minutes.
Euh je vous ai coupé dans votre
précédent développement. Quelque chose à
rajouter ? Oui. Et donc ce que je
disais, les les navires euh sont pas
assez nombreux, sont jamais assez
nombreux. Et peut-être juste répéter euh
en tout cas c'est le message que nous on
a essayé de passer. Les ONG, elles sont
pas là pour durer les ONG théoriquement.
Ah oui, il y en a beaucoup qui durent.
Les ONG humanitaires, elles durent
depuis longtemps, mais des fois, ils ont
le budget d'un petit état, non ?
Oui. Alors, on en est pas du tout là en
ce qui nous concerne, mais notre
vocation et elle est seule des ONG
humanitaires en général. elle est pas de
durée, elle est aussi de voilà de palier
un problème. Mais la le wakeup call, le
le comment dire le l'alerte enfin la
mobilisation, elle doit être du côté des
États. Euh
il y a moyen, l'Union européenne a moyen
512 millions d'habitants a moyen de
trouver un système pour venir au secours
de 20000 personnes. On parle de 20000
personnes en 2018
autant 10 ans
et a les moyens de d'avoir c'est c'est
le continent le plus riche du monde a
les moyens de de de développer une
diplomatie
une une une organisation qui fait en
sorte que tous ces problèmes sont pris à
la source tout ce que vous me décriviez
tout à l'heure qui n'a certainement pas
été fait effectivement les les 15
dernières années, il est pas trop tard
pour engager ce genre de dialogue et
pour travailler à une situation où les
gens ne se mettent pas en danger parce
que ça c'est oui c'est c'est une action
question qui n'a rien à voir. Euh la
dette française, c'est combien de
milliards ?
Euh j'ai appris ça à l'école. Euh j'ai
pas suivi récemment.
Le PIB français, c'est combien ?
J'ai pas révisé.
Je suis trop dedans, on travaille tous
les jours.
Quantitative easing, ça vous ça vous
parle ?
Quant
quantitative easing ? Aucune idée.
Bon allez, j'arrête de vous torturer sur
ça.
On finit toujours nos nos interviews par
laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations,
une bouteille à la mer,
quelque chose d'impérissable qui sera
transmis. Et là, on va rajouter "Quel
serait en plus de ça, quel serait votre
message aux vieilles générations, celle
des politiques, des intellectuels, des
responsables de la situation ?" Donc, un
truc pour les jeunes et un truc pour les
vieux. Un truc pour les jeunes, un truc
pour les vieux. Les jeunes euh
soyez passifs.
Soyez passif. Euh
c'est c'est cette question euh de
l'assistance de de quelques valeurs de
des droits de l'homme de voilà. C'est
pasvenu là par hasard. Euh euh
ça a été construit finalement assez
récemment dans l'histoire sur du long
terme.
C'est un vrai progrès euh et ça peut
être déconstruit et et aujourd'hui c'est
le risque qui nous pend
toute petite échelle sur un tout petit
sujet, celui du secours en mer, celui de
l'assistance mais ça peut être traduit
dans plein d'autres sur plein d'autres
thématiques. Euh c'est ça qu'on essaie
de défendre cette valeur là. Donc euh
laissez pas tomber, euh rien n'est
acquis et mobilisez-vous. Et je pense
que
en tout cas sur l'Aquarius euh oui, on a
on a vu que les jeunes se mobilisaient
euh nos équipes et cetera et que c'est
un mouvement au-delà de ça. Euh ce
mouvement, il doit grossir euh à terre,
en mer. Euh soutenez soutenez ce genre
d'initiative parce que c'est vos
valeurs, c'est les vôtres. Voilà.
Et pour les vieux ? Et pour les vieux
euh
sauter par la fenêtre, laisser la place
aux jeunes.
Ouais, des fois ça donne un peu cette
envie-là. Quoi que je sais pas trop dans
quelle catégorie faut que je me mette,
mais euh surtout
euh
donner une vision quoi, donner une
vision
euh euh
aujourd'hui de donner une vision qui
soit positive, euh
arrêter de de travailler sur la peur et
de vous faire embarquer dans de dans une
espèce de rhtorique où finalement il y a
il n'y a que la peur que la la sécurité
et on en oublie tout le reste, tout ce
qui fond de le le comment dire le le
contrat social, j'ai envie de dire, vous
vous avez des responsabilités euh
il y a de la place, même si c'est du
travail de long terme, même si c'est du
travail qui va peut-être pas payer
électoralement à très court terme, mais
il y a de la place pour développer un
narratif positif, un narratif prometteur
avec une vision avec avec voilà moi je
et là je saurai pour qui je vote en
l'occurrence.
Frédéric Penard, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]